[Music]
um i want to ask you about the
the very title of your book and the the
idea of something from nothing
um you are telling us
that matter arose spontaneously
out of nothing which i find an immensely
exciting idea
but many people will find it
mind-boggling
mind-boggling and offensive i think
maybe not as a hell with offensive but
mind-boggling
no no well you're not offended but i've
checked my email
um
it amazes me because the purpose of the
book to some extent is to say
something remarkable and it and and you
were kind enough and afterward to point
out the analogy to
darwin and i had some pretentious to
make it perhaps but
but the physicist stephen weinberg said
science doesn't make it impossible to
believe in god it just makes it possible
to not believe in god
because until you have science
everything's a miracle and
what darwin showed as you said at the
beginning of our discussion is this
miracle
is actually plausible from basic
principles of physics chemistry and
biology that you can
you can produce us without
a creator any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic
today's guest dr lawrence krauss
author of so many books uh to read their
titles would take us to the end of the
podcast
uh of course this is the number one uh
new york times best-selling
a universe from nothing uh he's written
the physics of star trek
and he's also written the physics of
climate change so this episode is just
called the physics of lawrence
and uh i want to welcome you to uh to my
podcast it's been three presidential
administrations since we were together
but it's good to see you it's really
good to see you i'm sorry in a way that
it's not uh
that we're not together in real life and
just virtually but hopefully that'll
change one day too
yeah you were so kind to speak at the
math for america
uh simon's foundation supported project
uh in 2012 and that's when we were last
together here in
uc san diego and in that time a lot has
happened as i said including you know
multiple presidential administrations so
actually the first question i want to
ask you today
lawrence is that i thought that you said
you would move to canada
if donald trump got reelected but you're
there now
and the president is joe biden what
gives it's just you know time lag
[Laughter]
it's it's the word it's the country he
he helped
create but i also said just just to make
it quite clear
that i'm obviously not a man of my word
i also said i'd move to canada if george
w bush was elected
and i did i did fly to canada right the
day after that election but but i didn't
stay
but it takes some time to to uh to to
um become an ex-patriot and um yeah
and in any case uh i i'd like to think
that you know better late than never
right right so uh the uh the books that
we're going to talk about today of
course we are going to talk about a
universe from nothing
multiverse string theory uh your vocal
uh
you know exponent proponent of
scientific reasoning
uh scientific thinking you are the
proprietor of the origins uh
podcast and the origins project
foundation
which has had many many speakers some of
whom i'm poached
so thank you uh lawrence for giving me
the idea to get shelley glashow on and
get noam chomsky on my podcast
and um they're very delightful and we
get to cover
different aspects of their personalities
but i do want to start with a universe
from nothing
which is uh subtitle why is there
something rather than nothing
and i'm also going to talk about your
pen previous book
i was about to say penultimate book but
i think you're so productive you're
probably writing with your hands right
now
another book uh but this book was sort
of uh with a forward by
uh an afterward by richard dawkins it's
very surprising to me lawrence again
that someone who is so well known in the
humanist or atheist
sort of community that you have a dog
named after the prince of the tribe
of priests of of the israelite uh tribes
you have a dog named levi is that
correct
i i don't know if i can do this i'm
going to try
oh my gosh we're seeing a levite yeah
seeing an invite right there out of out
of locals but there he is there
there he is wow yes and and um
and he appreciates the the shout out
that you just gave him
what is the world's you know foremost or
second foremost after
richard dawkins your friend why does the
you know most
prominent one of the most prominent
atheists have a dog named after the
tribes of
israel well i can give you three two
answers
um i don't know if any of them are true
but uh the first answer is that i didn't
choose the name
okay um but this the second answer is
his name is
is levi krauss right so now
now you get it okay that's right well he
is uh he's got good genes let me just
yeah exactly
you know one of my uh one of my dogs uh
doesn't uh
doesn't doesn't behave properly and we
always say you know it's bad genes but
then
we have to put them i have a third
answer too i just occurred to me his
mother was jewish
that's right well you know these the
levites in the temple service would
where they were you know of course very
powerful but they were subservient to
the kohanim the cohen's the
people that you meet cohen or kagan and
people like that and uh they would have
to wash their
uh their overlord's feet that was part
of their service so i hope levi your dog
will do the same to him
he won't be very happy to wash my feet
he's he he would be happy he licks them
actually there you go so i want to turn
now to
uh to books because uh you are a
prolific author
and actually the first time we almost
met we had a cup we had a close
encounter
of the cleveland kind in 1993 i
graduated from case western reserve
university
and that was a year you became chairman
of the physics department
and so i think we just missed by a
couple of weeks but at the graduation
the previous chair uh who i can't
remember who it was
uh he gave all the graduates there were
only 13 of us it was
it's a great school it remains a great
school sure but he gave all
all of us physics majors a copy of
stephen weinberg's
uh dreams of a final theory which
could not have come at worse timing
because of course later that year
the superconducting super collider which
stephen was advocating for and editing
was canceled um i want to ask you about
books i heard
you say once that you were turned on to
what we call popular science
uh by a man that i'm very fond of and i
actually have
him incarnate or perhaps in miniature
form i have a lot of puppets lawrence
maybe someday you'll have a puppet
but this man here you see this guy do
you recognize this
it was that could be galileo on russia
is galileo yeah it's a telescope you see
that
yeah well i didn't know if it's a snake
he was holding but i assumed it was a
telescope i actually have a lot of
i'm a big fan of galileo's by the way he
had a great sense of humor
so tell me about that i want to talk i'm
actually recording i've taken upon
myself with the help of carlo rivelli
to uh to make the first ever audiobook
version of the dialogues
that's never been done before in human
history so uh carlo myself and a good
friend of mine lucio pichurillo
are recording the first ever audiobook
of any of galileo's books
in italian uh what's that in italian
uh yeah c c no no
so i figured maybe you could you could
do yeah carlo or ravelli of course is a
renowned uh author and thinker
uh advocate of loop condom gravity we're
gonna get into all that but let's get
back to galileo galileo means so much to
me
because he really was the first
scientist he was a popular author and
stephen j gould
in the book that i tried to get an audio
version of and found to my chagrin it
didn't exist
and had then had to make it myself
steven j gould called him
one of the greatest writers of
non-fiction in human history
yeah i mean superior didn't know i've
said and you may have if you've read
things i've said i've said it many times
that it upsets me that we we have these
great books
programs at universities and you have to
read ulysses but you don't have to read
the dialogues
the dialogues are easier to read and
funnier certainly i would think
and um uh and yeah so galileo was was a
role model in many ways but
but but um what what uh
probably well the reason i read
about him a book not by him but i read a
book about him and i was
11 or 12 for in grade in grade 6 i think
and uh it was probably recommended in
school i was in some enrichment program
and um and uh it really had a huge
impact on me because
it made me think and i've since
discovered this isn't true but it made
me think of scientists as brave
individuals
fighting for truth and and and and
willing to you know confront
uh obviously uh pseudoscience
superstition whatever
and and so that brave uh effort of his
really really resonated with me i
remember at the time thinking that but
also the the notion of
of being the first one you know to see
the moons of jupiter and
and uh and changing obviously the way we
think we think about the world and
in fact i one of my books uh fear of
physics
um really begins with galileo in an
important way because really i mean he
changed everything in such an important
way we don't
we don't really give him credit and i
one of the things that when i've taught
as i have over the years i've taught
many courses
standardly called physics for poets
courses in universities
when i taught at yale um which is where
i taught right before i went to become
chair at case western
um i i sort of changed it to physics for
lawyers
because i only because i met a lot of
pre-law students but i never met any
poets
in any of the classes that i taught but
um uh
i always made a point of requiring them
to read galileo because it's it's
readable
and and um and the utility of using the
socratic method
which he does and and with humor but
also
pedagogically there's a lot of evidence
that that the only way to really
learn something is to confront your own
misconceptions and
that's precisely the way more or less he
teaches things and he had great thought
experiments well before einstein
he he would have had the italian version
of ge duncan experiments
um and and they're great and they're
wonderful
wonderful ways of realizing your own
misconceptions and i've used them once
i was once in in in another life
lecturing before many
leaders of the free world it turned out
um and i
and i and i asked them you know i had a
piece of paper and
a book and asked which would which would
hit the hit the ground first and
and of course they they all said the
book but then i did the standard thing
which i do with class say why and
and of course many of them would say
books heavier
and then i you know and then i scrunched
up the paper into a ball
and and and and let's drop and they you
know and that was shocking that but it
was really a version of what what
uh what galio did and so his pedagogy
was great but as a scientist
he really was i used to say was the
father of modern science but then
i actually read a piece by his father
who was a musician by the way
yeah yeah and it's a and it's a great
discussion of the nature of truth and
empirical evidence and i kind of
realized
well it's clear why galileo grew up to
be the way he was his father was a
was a passionate advocate for truth and
evidence and so i like to think of
galilee's father as the father of modern
science since galileo was the first
science modern scientist
that's right that's his uh his uh
his his heritage his legacy of that yes
his father was a was a
musician and then he would use things
like tempo and
and so forth later on influencing him
you know to take his pulse yeah
that's how he timed and i don't know if
you've been you probably have then
you've probably been to the
museum in florence the sign which i find
frankly much more fascinating than all
the other art museums in florence
i found that museum is it so and it's it
and when you go to florence and it's
busy because you can't get into the art
museums you can always get into the
museum of science and not only see
galileo's finger but see the
the actual instruments that he used to
discover the laws of motion and change
the way we think about the world
in a way that in some ways was more not
only more profound than what
maybe what anyone else did but the rest
of modern science was impossible without
what without galileo and newton
basically newton you know newton's first
law at least is just sort of a natural
extension of what galileo did and
and so newton was lucky i mean newton
was amazing but certainly lucky to be
born a generation or two after galileo
yeah yeah he took the mantle on i think
on the year that galileo died right
he was born on christmas day at least as
everyone always says that lawrence but
they don't realize that the gregorian
calendar changed
uh yeah so it's actually i think he was
born what we would call january 4th or
something now but i want to read a
passage from
siddirius nuncius which i think is the
book
you know uh that with the aid of the of
the telescopic
lever figuratively moved the earth
more than any other scientific
instrument more than the large hadron
collider more than ligo
and i want to read it and i want to
particularly pay attention to
the second half of this passage so
galileo says in cedarius nuncius the
starry messenger says with the aid of
the spyglass
the universe may be observed so well
that
all the disputes that for so many
generations
have vexed philosophers are destroyed
by visible by visible certainty and we
are
liberated from their wordy arguments
you're no fan of philosophers if i
recall correctly
again it's a bad rap i i get accused of
that just for making a few jokes but
anyway
i want to get to that because you know
when you spoke here i got pushed back
once uh
you know for the cloaking that you gave
from the string theorist uh you've
pushed on philosophers especially in the
wake of a review by a prominent
uh philosopher of a universe from
nothing uh what what is this kind of uh
you know
of course galileo and newton were
considered natural philosophers whatever
that means
very different from what is your beef
with philosophers
i i look i don't have really beef with
it at all but
but let me say that the difference
what made natural i mean science was
natural philosophy i mean so it grew out
of philosophy so there's no denying that
but then you can also say
philosophy growth of religion but
philosophy isn't religion and science
isn't philosophy
sure we we respect the legacy but
the fact what he said in the starry
messenger there just by looking through
a telescope he can destroy
the debates it is a great example of the
difference
of of the scientific
method the scien the whole methodology
that he he
epitomized but and also largely created
compared to say
aristotle who's who who no doubt was a
wonderful philosopher and was and now
i've
people have made me appreciate him more
than i had before but who
but one of the things aristotle said is
that men and women have a different
number of
teeth and and and what galileo could
have said to him and would have said to
him is
why do you look in their mouths and
count and
and that's the difference now so look
but you know he did do something amazing
lawrence
aristotle the only scientific thing i
think that he did aristotle that is that
wasn't wrong
is he said that whales aren't fish yeah
i don't know how the hell he did that
but but he did it so but some people
have also told me his but some of his
biology was actually better than i'm
giving credit for it but let's not let's
not we didn't come here to
either bury or praise aristotle so let's
let's get back to
um so philosophy we all do philosophy
and philosophy
as an endeavor which is really logical
thinking critical analysis i mean it's a
central part
of of all intellectual disciplines so so
let's
be clear about that what
the the beef that i have is the people
who
and i don't have a beef some
philosophers
well i don't even want to put it this
way the claim that you have to study
philosophy to be able to do physics is
just wrong
that's all it's just empirically wrong
as i like to say most physicists can't
spell philosophy
but but it's but and so it's it's not a
i mean the more you read of any subject
the more you may appreciate your own
discipline so there's no denying that
but
but but you simply it's you simply don't
have to
and no and most scientists don't read
philosophy moreover
the philosophy of science which is an
interesting field
when it comes to physics it's really
irrelevant i mean in the sense that the
questions of interest to those
philosophers signs
which may be interesting intellectual
questions and i don't deny they might be
my only point is that they don't
influence the progress of physics
so they're some of them are incredibly
interesting questions
but they don't influence the progress of
physics and that's just an empirical
fact it's not an opinion
it's just a fact now the the
the the key point here i think
is that when philosophy influences
science the most
is in a discipline where the questions
aren't well framed
when the questions aren't well framed
philosophy is a wonderful discipline for
helping frame good questions that drive
that field forward
and a field for example that i would
argue isn't
maybe in such a state is is is sort of
has to do with brain science
consciousness okay where a lot what is
consciousness
you know is a question that if is very
usually
you when you ask that you get a vague
answers at best
and so that's why there's a lot of
interplay i think between
neuroscientists and and philosophers and
when it comes to brain science and i
know a few
uh philosophers who are dan dennett and
others who are
who are who are interact very strongly
with neuroscientists but in physics the
questions are well framed and the
questions
you know we've we've evolved so much
since time of galileo
that really the field you know to really
make progress you have to you have to
understand the intellectual baggage of
the field which isn't philosophy
and that's true now what is interesting
is that the results of physics can
change
can then be utilized later by not just
philosophy but other people
to change their worldview and that's
what the
universe or nothing is all about and
some people object to the fact that
that science changes the meaning of
certain things including nothing
the word nothing and and my ad my answer
to that is that
well that's just the example of learning
i mean and and and so
um so science changes it changes a lot
it when i talk when i've debated with
some christian apologists for example
classical logic be useful but when it
comes to quantum mechanics it's it's
it it we often have to throw it out the
window
and it's not because we want to it's or
we have a predilection it's the nature
is the way nature is and so so any in
any case i have
i think you know philosophy is a
different discipline is incredibly
important and i've read philosophers and
they've had a great intellectual legacy
and some of the work they do in their
own discipline it may be incredibly
difficult and interesting
but it just doesn't impact on the field
of physics and yeah that's not a
pejorative that's just a fact
one of the main characters in the
greatest story ever told
so far why are we here is plato yeah uh
he plays uh
really an outsized role in that book uh
even more than the person we're gonna
turn to
next but uh i can't resist because you
brought up galileo you brought up
consciousness
galileo was also one of the first people
to tackle the problem the hard problem
of consciousness
almost to no avail uh but uh what i love
there hasn't been much progress since
exactly but in physics look at the
comparison so i like that ratio test
that you're proposing as a rubric for at
least assessing which problems can be
attacked by rigorous hard scientific
uh thinking and data and evidence and
which ones may be forever locked away
free will as you say and uh and
consciousness perhaps being
of two i i i'm i'm not as pessimistic i
just
you know we have a long way to go but i
i haven't seen any limits right now
i still haven't you know people ask what
are the limits of science how we say
well if i knew
you know if i knew i'd have to know what
you know what the limits are right i
mean it's just
it's kind of crazy but i don't see a
brick wall yet there's
there are problems that are very hard
and i and i people think i'm joking when
i say
i've been on the stage with many
biologists when i say i do physics
because it's easy
because it is easy compared to
consciousness and
and and so it's not surprising that
we've made a lot more progress but i
don't see an ultimate barrier to
understanding it eventually and maybe
you know
i'm agnostic about that yeah and i want
to talk about uh prospects for
a.i galileo or as i call him a i or
galil aio
we'll talk about that later and if
computers are even capable of doing such
things as
galileo or einstein did we'll get to
that later but last part last
direct reading from galileo since i
can't resist uh really involves what's
very little known about it he also was a
great
uh you know observer of the human
condition and i believe he came up with
what's known as the dunning-kruger
effect which will segue
back to a universe from nothing so what
he says in segredo who is the character
i'm playing
in dialogue segreto says this
uh it always seems to me rashness on the
part of some who want to make human
abilities the measure of what nature can
do
on the contrary there is not a single
effect in nature
even the least that exists such that the
most ingenious theorists
can arrive at a complete understanding
of it in fact this vain presumption
of understanding everything lawrence can
have no other basis than ever
understanding
anything for anyone who had experienced
just once
the perfect understanding of one single
thing
and had truly tasted how that knowledge
was accomplished
he would recognize that of the infinity
of other truths
he understands nothing i want to ask you
lawrence have you ever
understood something that you feel was
sort of
as high a level a discovery that you
made
perhaps for the first time in human
intellectual history
once or twice i may let me let me say
there are a few times i made some
profound discoveries but they but nature
didn't
didn't choose to agree with them they
could they could have been right they
weren't
mathematically wrong as a theorist you
know as an experimentalist
you're either right or wrong based on
the experiment but as a theorist you can
propose things that are perfectly
consistent but nature may not you know
there was a one
once i i was sure i had the solution of
what something called the solar neutrino
problem that was beautiful but nature
didn't do that
but i think the one time that i really
did
really feel that was when i was first
became convinced there was a
cosmological constant and and
and no one believed it and uh and um
and spent a few years before i even
convinced i think my colleague
and co-author michael turner before we
finally produced that paper in 1995
arguing that the evidence suggested that
70
of the universe was an empty sp the
energy of empty space and we did it and
i must say
in some sense it was a realization and
that i guess i felt that was the first
one to kind of really appreciate that
but at the same time to be fair
i a large part of wanting to publish
that was was
was the decision that i was convinced
that it was a crazy possibility but it
was the only possibility to me that
agreed with all the data
so what it meant to me was that some of
the data was wrong so
i really wrote that to point out that
hey some of the cosmological data must
be wrong because
if it isn't you're driven to this insane
possibility
and the insane possibility turned out to
be right so but
but so that's probably um
uh for me the most explicit example of
you know again if you're a theorist you
often you go through these
phases almost like death of people
death of loved ones we in almost every
stage of uh
well i mean sometimes you're just
pushing things forward a little bit but
if you're ever
proposing something particularly new you
go through the stage of love and you
think oh this is this is this could
really explain things and then
and and then it gets moderated and then
generally the experiments show it's
wrong or something and
so you go through this grief period as
well so i've had this hope
many times that that i might be the
first one to understand things but the
the cause the dark energy was probably
the most concrete example of
potentially sort of being right and that
uh brings us to the next
uh stage of the conversation which will
get into you know nothingness
etc and this involves the beginning not
of one of your books
but of the recent book by your debate
partner stephen c
meyer who is a christian apologist and
he is a
uh he has been on the show we have
talked about his new book return
of the god hypothesis i'll put a link to
it right over here
don't don't bother don't do that to
service to your terry listeners well
lawrence you know what i actually wrote
a blurb for that book
and you'll be amused why because he sent
me this book and uh
and in it he said you know i've seen
your videos and i've had some videos
critical of
string theory and the multiverse and
stuff i hope we can get into but
um but he said you know i thought you
might find this book interesting
and if you wouldn't mind considering a
blurb you know it's got brian josephson
which you know you know is a
controversial figure but yeah yeah i
thought it'd be interesting to have a
blurb from a guy who
won the nobel prize right whose name
brian and then another blurb from
o'brien
it was your that was your rationale okay
well i was pleased to see that at least
in an article he wrote afterwards that
he claimed that writing that book was
motivated by
in part by a debate he had with me in
toronto where he was you're the opening
line you're in the opening line of the
book and the book uh goes through
basically trying to make the
argument from um from design essentially
that
two different instantiations of
information
lead and he has a phd from cambridge in
philosophy of science just just for the
record
uh and we were talking about philosophy
of science uh just a minute ago but
the the claim that he makes is you know
i'll leave aside the dna you know that
requires a mind etc
but that the low entropy you know
starting point of the universe
uh leads to uh you know there aren't
things in the universe that decrease
entropy
according to the second law and he goes
through the bourne gl the board guth the
lincoln
theorem actually does a good job
explaining what that is he talks about
um you know alternative proposals he
gets into uh
all sorts of all sorts of mathematical
wic rotations and he goes after stephen
hawking
and a brief history which i've actually
taken big issue with stephen hawking for
kind of
literally in that book he says i'm going
to do a trick don't pay attention to it
it's just a mathematical and he does
what's called a wick rotation which
you're very familiar with
and then all of a sudden time has no
boundary okay so i i think that's kind
of nonsensical
steven was an old friend of mine i think
i know why he did said that but anyway
i won't i won't say and then there's
also so much uh of so many of these
books nowadays that mention
god etc the god equation the god
hypothesis
anyway what do you make of this notion
of the uh
is it a problem that the universe seemed
to start
unless you apply the alpertine which i
know you might have issues with
uh you know this past hypothesis
instantiation by fee out of a low
entropy state
talk to me about what what do you think
of as a problem
for the in the ordinary big bang board
goof lincoln
uh boundary proposals what do you think
of it as a problem is it a problem or
people
i think people are first of all i think
people are people like steve meyer are
trying to point out what
they think are problems because they've
heard people talk about problems that
aren't really problems
and and by the way i should say i've
written a
a response to to demonstrate most of his
misconceptions
um in in a in a room in a
uh called cosmology without design i
think
in the in the magazine which is a lovely
magazine online called
inference yeah um put a link to that
edited by uh
yeah dave berlinsky and and shelly
glacial in fact is is the uh i think
editor-in-chief of it or something
but um anyway so i tried to explain
there why the
what the misconceptions that somehow
cosmology points to design was
but look the point is that all
all you need is a universe that can have
at some
from some my arbitrarily microscopically
small region
inflation and the rest just happens
naturally so i don't see what
i mean concerns about the state before
inflation
um are interesting we we have no
evidence about them
if inflation happened it erased the
evidence largely
what happened before them and um and and
we also know we don't have a theory of t
equals zero either
so where people start talking about
problems in areas where the physics
really isn't well defined
what i say is well okay that's fine
let's talk about the physics
where we can understand it and i and i
and in fact my in my book um
adam which is it which was a history of
an atom from the beginning of the
universe to the end what am i actually
one of my favorite books in a way yeah
um i really began i think it's only it's
useful to begin
our history of the universe back to a
time when our
both our theories and our empirical data
allow us to
reliably extrapolate before that
it's just pure speculation i'm sure we
can talk about it but it's just words
and when we think about uh you know
obviously a universe from nothing is
making the case for
um some pre-existing state of the
universe the one thing that steven
points out and others have pointed out
too paul steinhardt einstein professor
of natural science at princeton
university neil turock
uh fellow canadian uh uh at least
yeah yeah he's a transplant yeah um so
and student of stephen hawking
right um this uh this notion that
uh you don't need a necessarily need
a uh a singularity you don't need to
have
a you know quantum gravity i want to ask
you i've asked this of lenny suskin
i've had sir roger penrose on after he
won the nobel prize i claim
i hear this uroboros statement this
tautological statement
which is that we need quantum gravity to
understand
the physics of singularities at the core
of a black hole
and at the origin of the universe and
then why do we need that because the
universe began with a singular but
there's no evidence and then as you said
the universe hides
evidence of its own origin now i have a
vested interest in this as
one of the four co-leaders of the
simon's observatory looking for
primordial gravitational wave b modes
i i this my life my job security does
depend on this as often sinclair
so this is an area and as i spent many
years of my life
discussing those very gravitational
waves as signals
that's right from the beginning of time
um and in fact actually happy to say
that i was asked as you probably know by
physical
letters to write the companion piece uh
to
to that paper that your book behind you
is based on that's right
and and because because i was ready and
happily you're ahead of your
collaboration you know i had all the
data in advance and and so i could do
that but anyway
um you're look i think the point is we
do
if we avoid a singularity which
i think is most physicists would
speculate is
likely since we don't like singularities
the way to avoid it is
is probably a theory of quantum gravity
so
in my book and in my work but in my book
in particular i talk about what is an
extremely plausible hypothesis about how
you and in fact actually one that began
began with work when i was a graduate
student and then and then
i i chose not to publish it and alex
felin can actually end up the rep
just down the corner for me published
the paper at the
almost the same time i was working with
a friend of mine ian affleck on it
um uh but you know it plausibly
you can create a universe of finite size
as a quantum fluctuation and then and
then you don't have to
then you avoid that that question if you
want about the singularity
but you don't avoid the question of
quantum gravity because the creation of
such a
of such a microscopic universe
non-singular but microscopic that
process
is a quantum mechanical process that
involves gravity so
we can speculate about its likelihood
but we can't we can't calculate
the details if you wish without a theory
of quantum gravity so
you kind of need a theory of quantum
gravity to either whether there's a
singularity
or or not uh to really frame the initial
conditions of
of our universe which is which as
physicists really that's i mean
more or less once you have the initial
conditions then the rest is sort of
you know just not it's just easy in
principle
um but but the but the plausibility the
fact that we know a theory of quant
we know that space and time are the
variables of gravity
and that if gravity is quantum
mechanical those two variables become
quantum mechanical
and therefore since they're quantum
fluctuations you should be able to
spontaneously create space times that is
incredibly plausible and any and it's
hard to imagine any theory of quantum
gravity that wouldn't have such a
possibility
but but but that's all you can do at
some level
um and the rest is talk and and but but
that's all you need to
to do what i i did in the book really to
point out that
that um that ultimately the surprising
thing and this is where it's signed i
mean
the intent of that book was really to
discuss the revolutions that have taken
place in cosmology over the last 50
years
and but and also to point and also
certainly to
hit at religion because after evolution
the last bastion of sort of of of god
was in somehow creation of the universe
after you showed that you can have life
without god then then and then the next
you can have evolution
i know i know i know i know i know
evolution doesn't and darwin never
talked
back darvin said we would never
understand the origin of life it would
be like understanding the origin of
matter
yeah exactly and i've quoted it and we
exactly and we're hopefully
understanding the origin of matter
sometimes
yeah but but uh the point is that that
you know that's often held as hey how
could you create a universe without
without a supernatural being because how
could you create a universe with a
a 100 billion galaxies each containing
100 billion stars
a lot of stuff if you didn't have stuff
there at the beginning and
and what's worth pointing out is that
that argument itself is just simply
fallacious whether or not you buy the
other details as alan talked about from
alan good talked about with inflation
you get a great free lunch
because gravity has negative energy you
can get
what apparently is something from
nothing very easily and that was
a discussion i wanted to have in my book
to point that out that you
don't need something supernatural to
have a universe full of stuff
if there was no stuff in the beginning
but why i think that's that's really
profoundly surprising it certainly was
if you'd asked me
if you'd asked me in the 1970s or early
80s i would have
i would have thought that was i would
have said that's nonsense but anyway
so i'm sitting in the office um as you
remember from visiting here
yeah this is the office once occupied by
jeffrey burbidge and
uh his wife margaret left some late
great margaret burbidge uh
she's one of the titans of astronomy of
all time she left
some of these plates of from telescopes
from before i was born
uh taken here uh this is actually from
yeah two months before i was born in
1971
also taken and and so forth but as you
know jeff was a
major opponent of uh not only of
inflation but of of the
of the big bang itself and in fact he
was one of the foremost
uh proponents of the quasi-steady state
university
with his late great colleague uh sir
fred hoyle who was one who's a titanic
influence on
on cosmology but he used to say and also
wrote great science fiction by the way
wonderful books yeah yeah he wrote uh
once that
people cosmologists practicing
cosmologists card-carrying cosmologists
were overwhelmed i quote by their uh in
their
appreciation of the big bang because of
their love of genesis 1-1
and i think actually you're you know
obviously bored with lincoln and
inflation allen's work and linday's work
steinhart's work
um they've uh they is sort of more of a
fellow traveler
with uh with the biblical narrative than
is paul steinhardt
who has all right i mentioned but i
meant in his initial incarnation as one
of the
founding fathers of new inflation not in
his now
role as one of the most prominent
anti-inflation activists that's such a
thing could be mentioned
so yeah well well well let's get into
that because yeah he's uh he's a titanic
influence on
cosmology and and is doing really
interesting alternative work but and
we'll get into that the importance of
of non-mainstream um uh voices in cosmo
but getting back to hoyle
hoyle thought the big bang was too was
an inflation he'd probably say the same
thing was too much like genesis 1 1 and
we
cosmologists like you lawrence you're
overwhelmed by genesis you just love
genesis
but wouldn't an eternal universe
wouldn't that make more sense in other
words
we're in and i give this to stephen
meyer
where does hilbert's space come from you
know where we're is an instantiation of
of of a you know sean carroll talks
about this and his talk
uh god is not a good theory um yeah so
where where
where does the hilbert's place come from
and why not why not travel in the
in the camp of uh of a cyclic model like
sir roger
first of all the answer to where silver
switch comes is it's quite simple we
don't know we don't know if quantum
mechanics
arises only in our universe or if it's a
universal
um property of nature and we don't and
physics in some sense doesn't answer
those kind of questions
but i think the answer to
well look first of all it doesn't matter
what people think are prettier or nicer
a cyclic universe is very pretty but it
doesn't really matter whether it's
pretty
the question is one thing it's farther
away from god well no yeah
who cares whether it's f the point is we
shouldn't be driven by our hatred or
love of god and no and as far as i know
no physicists
are to first approximation um i mean
it is worth pointing out that the father
of the big bang really
was you know why he was a catholic
priest he was a priest and and
was wonderful but he also when the pope
when the pope specifically said
hey this validates genesis he wrote no
he wrote the puppet said no you
don't say that because it's a scientific
theory and you shouldn't abuse it
but so sure it is a
i mean if if there's one thing that the
catholic church could jump up and down
and say see we told you so
it would be that because it was the
conventional wisdom in science before 19
well certainly in 1925 say or even
before 1925
that the universe was static and eternal
that was a scientific view
and probably specifically because it
wasn't genesis
i mean among other things there was no
evidence of anything of any evolution of
the universe
and so that and then the big bang was
discovered and it demonstrated that our
universe had a beginning most likely
and the catholic church could rightly
jump up and down and say see we told you
so
but of course that's just v one is just
vague words one is reality one's got
stupid stories associated with one's got
one's got empirical evidence
uh but but i think the bottom line is
that if
no one what we've grown up
to realize that our universe is not all
there is
most likely and therefore to say that
our universe had a beginning is not to
suggest
what really matters now is the
multiverse okay
that could be eternal if you don't like
it but but
but i like but for for me
what i like better is an argument that
stephen hawking gave and and i so same
thing
if are you let's say our universe is all
there is
space and time are coupled if space
comes into existence then time comes
into existence
okay so there was no time before the big
bang
and the question what happened before
the big bang is simply not a good
question
the whole question of causality and
everything else goes out the window
because if
if there is no before then the
traditional notions of causality and
and inference that of course apologists
and others love to jump on
is is a is a wrong question it's like
you know what's the as richard said i
think in my book i don't know what
somewhere what's the color of jealousy
although we know that screen
but um uh so i think the point is i love
the
the no the realization that we may have
to just change our notions
if of of sort of of of causality itself
if time began with the big bang because
there was no before
and then and and and you know i love the
idea that we're forced to change our
notions but
but i suspect more likely is that our
universe had a beginning in in
in a in the midst of of something which
from which
some universes are beginning right now
and some universes are ending
which is a multiverse everything i know
about
about theoretical physics right now
suggests to me that's the most likely
possibility
but um but i'm not wedded to it but
by the way um
i i uh
some people would say of course you
can't measure your multiverse but the
wonderful thing and i wrote a paper
um uh uh pointing this out and then
another one paper with my friend frank
wilchick about this that that uh
if we did measure gravitational waves
from inflation it would demonstrate the
gravities of quantum theory but it will
also in some ways
give us a way of proving that there is a
multiverse
well i want to get into that because i
read that paper and i've had frank on to
discuss that paper
uh in the past year but i confess i
don't fully understand uh
the quantum nature you know one of my
professors there professor eck at case
western you might remember thomas of
course yeah yeah thomas his boss really
well
yeah so he uh needs to talk about you
know we we say classical physics so we
should say quantal physics
anyway um getting into that uh in what
when i think about a quantum mechanical
experiment you know all the time we're
going to talk about why there's so many
theorists writing you know
popularizations of science but not as
many experimentalists but
whenever i hear a theorist talk about
it's always spooky action at a distance
like what constitutes the quantum to a
theorist like you is
you know spooky action in a distance or
it's entanglement or
it is the double slit experiment in the
many worlds and things split up
anyway how would bicep two in in the in
the counter factual universe where
you know my my book is winning the nobel
prize uh how
how in such a in such a universe um does
the
detection of a classical gravitational
wave
d you know manifest the impromptu of a
quantum process
to 381 000 years earlier well
uh because okay um
if it's a scale invariant spectrum
then there's only one dimensional
parameter that determines
the um the the the intensity if you wish
of gravitational waves
and that's in some sense the energy
scale at which they're created
okay and what what we showed i mean
i showed in in explicit calculation and
then when i talked to frank about it we
came up with a
a dimensional analysis argument which is
really really wonderful which
basically shows that given it's just
given that the only dimensional
parameter
is the scale of in inflation if you want
to call it that but the scale at which
this scale and variance spectrum is
created
you can show that that
spectrum the power in that spectrum
vanishes
in the limit where the planck's constant
vanishes
and so the you know you can jump up and
down and talk about spooky action and
distance and everything else but the
point is that
that the finite all of it comes down
to the fact that planck's constant the
fundamental constant of quantum
mechanics is a finite number
it affects the energy levels of atoms it
it
it it really demonstrates the quantum
nature of matter and energy or
more the initial version which is that
you know that things are
that all states are quantized in energy
levels
and if if hbar if the plane's constant
went to zero
then atoms would have a continuum of
levels instead of a a finite spectrum
and it turns out and i can show in the
blackboard pretty easily but not
probably not here at the right time but
sometime
i'll come there and show you yeah um it
by simple
literally undergraduate level
dimensional analysis
that given given the the dimensional the
and it has to be a scale and variance
spectrum for this to be the case by the
way
um that you can show that that vanishes
and no matter how it's calculated it
will vanish
in the limit where quantum mechanics
goes away so
if it's there then then then then
um and it's a gravitational process then
gravity must be governed by
by quantum mechanics and would the same
hold true
you know if i tell you i've got uh
johnson noise stochastic scale invariant
i detect it in my
uh radio receiver um from no
the dimensions are different okay sorry
i
i shouldn't interrupt but i know i think
i know where you're heading and the
point is yeah it turns out the unique
it just you have to know that there's
only two quantities i should say
there's there's not one dimensional
quantity if it's a if it's a
gravitational process
there's another dimensional quantity
which is which is uh uh
the gravitational constant newton's
constant and newton's constant has
dimensions
that's what makes it different than than
electromagnetism and
when you say the only two dimensional
quantities are newton's constant
which tells you the strength of gravity
yeah and the scale at which
this thing is produced when you combine
them
you show advantages unless uh unless the
the the
in the in the classical limit but that's
not true for electromagnetism it's not
true for
that same dimensional analysis counting
doesn't work yeah i wonder
yeah i wonder though if i'm wrong
actually because to get to get the
mode counting correctly in the blackbody
case you do need to
actually include the phase factor for
including planck's constant
but i guess the inference i was trying
to make is if you detect a classical
wave
you know and but your point is that it's
a background and stochastic
it has to have those two features yeah
yeah it has to be not just us
yeah exactly for example we've detected
classical gravitational waves from
from from colliding black holes but in
no way that does that
in any way prove that gravity is a
quantum theory it's a very different
kind of argument
right and then the only other response i
would get is that at as you know because
you worked on this for decades
uh that there is so called second
second-order tensor perturbation any
time
i had alan lightman on this week and i
told him his my favorite of all his
books
is a problem book in gravity and general
relativity uh so we talked about that
for an hour no no we didn't do that
but i said there's a problem in there in
chapter three where he talks about on
the massachusetts turnpike where you
probably spent many hours of your life
a motorist is shaking his fist at
another motorist and how much
gravitational wave energy does he
produce and i said well but i'm saying
to you now
rather that the early universe even in
the bouncing cosmological models
has a vast amount of matter and a vast
amount of acceleration
and so there are second order tensor
perturbations which would produce
yeah so if we detect those then that
is those are implicitly classical in
other words there is no quantum gravity
in
the cyclic or aeon model of sir roger or
whatever
so yeah i wonder you know it would there
be a way and it would produce a
background i mean you'd see a stochastic
background gravitational waves come the
metric reverberation's a second order
so i wonder is it possible to falsify it
and and maybe maybe not but i think as
well
i think there i've written paper we can
talk about it i i think there are ways
to false fight by looking at
at a few things the ratio of density
because the second order fluctuations
are related to
density fluctuations and so relating
relating it to density fluctuations you
can try and see
comparing what we would call in and this
is probably too much for any of your
listeners scalar
vector and tensor perturbations
comparing them you can i believe
falsify it and i've thought a lot about
it but yeah i'd love to talk about that
maybe we do we do on this
channel we also do something called
journal club uh where i have uh eminent
scholars
uh come and talk about uh deep dives
into research because
my audience is they do like to go pretty
deep and stuff and whenever i have a
you know politician on or you know
somebody i had the mayor of san diego on
you know they kind of tune out and and i
loved or the mayoral candidates
um i want to ask a question about uh
about
you know whether or not there are
as a natural correlation and perhaps
you're surprisingly
aberrant in the sense that most of the
supporters of the multiverse are fellow
traveling along with string theory and
you are very very prominent
you know kind of outspoken um uh you
know critic of of string theory and what
it might mean and then you see
see i get i get labeled well i get laid
many things and
we talked about this on clubhouse no no
i know but but i'm a critic of hype
is what i'm agreeing when it comes to
science so i was a critic of the hype
associated with string theory
i wrote a whole book called hiding in
the mirror which is really about
the search for extra dimensions and it
explains why string theory is very well
motivated
so this this as a as a fundamental area
of physics
it's very well motivated i happen to
think probably more than loop corner of
gravity but
but but um but it's the hype it's the
fact that that you know it's just
it's this interesting idea that was
claimed to be able to
tell us everything and it's told us
virtually nothing except providing an
incredible amount useful mathematical
tools
to apply to other physical systems
anyway yeah actually i i want to turn to
that because your friend uh stephen
hawking late great stephen hawking
he would often you know concede bets
and on the basis of uh of of a proof
from
say juan maldasena in you know
five-dimensional ads cft
uh you can recover beckon scene hawking
you can get all sorts of information
but i want to ask you like i mean i i
feel like he conceded that too easily
like
how do we know that i think it was the
ncft even exists it's true no i
i think i think look uh uh steve is a
wonderful man but he's also a very
astute
um promoter and and
i think he did some things he did
because he he realized they'd get
attention
and i i tend to think that was the case
yeah by the way i'm
really pissed that i had i had what i
thought should have been a famous bet
with
with hawking and will check which i won
oh wow and dennis overby was
was there to uh but but certify it to to
but he he claims he he you know he's
just too
shy i think he didn't want to anyway but
i it was early on i
right after it was shortly after um the
dark energy was discovered that i argued
and there was a great deal of
of all this hype about oh quit testing
somebody will be able to measure
uh you know that it's changing and blah
blah and i and i said within a decade
there will be no nothing that will be
able to tell us that
that it it it the dark energy is
changing
there'll be nothing that will tell you
that it is a cosmological constant and
therefore there's nothing that tells you
it isn't
and and there'll be no there'll be no
observational data and they say oh no no
no within a decade
so so both frank and stephen were wrong
and neither of them had well stephen
died and frank has refused to admit he
made that bet
but but i said because in his book which
i have somewhere here and i talk a
beautiful question
written in 2014 uh he makes a claim that
within five years super
symmetry will be discovered so i feel of
frank that
as sir roger penrose once said though
the quickest way to get rich is to make
a bet with stephen hawking
because no matter what you bet he's
going to concede because of the
attention i think
and uh and oftentimes he would have two
different positions
but you don't become rich by betting
with stephen hawking you just get some
notoriety
yeah you got a subscription a playboy or
something yeah yeah something like that
but anyway stephen stephenson think
about and i never got to
i never got to either we just bet a very
expensive bottle of wine
and i never i never got it and it
doesn't really matter but anyway um
yeah so but but i don't think
so first of all whether i you know
putting people in camps worries me yeah
i'm not
i'm not a fan of this
claimed progress in strength here i have
great respect
for for the work that's being done in
many ways which i mean i edwin is
another friend of mine and someone i
admire tremendously for their abilities
um but but you know but string theory
isn't quantum corner man it hasn't
explained the world
but but that has nothing to do with them
whether
a multiverse is a very sensible idea the
the the really sensible multiverse
the well-motivated multiverse is not the
multiverse of string theory
the extra-dimensional many universes the
the only one that is inescapable it
seems to me is the one from inflation
and and that multiverse namely there are
many universes in
you know there need not be extra
dimensions but they're in in four
dimensions in three plus one dimensions
there there are many spatially separated
universes
uh uh over time isn't it
in is generally an explicit inescapable
prediction of inflation
and i find that the well-motivated
multiverse the the notion
that there may be many other universes
in higher dimensions
i mean i was very happy that i got one
of my students ramen syndrome
tenure but but uh uh uh when he proposed
large universes i guess with lisa
randall but
but uh but i've always thought it was
ugly as sin
mm-hmm yeah it's it's i guess the the
the only sense i i kind of pejoratively
say that they might be fellow travelers
is that
some claim that both are unfalsifiable
first before i go there i want to ask
you a question i mean you hear this a
lot as a canard
and experimentalists will say things
like oh well you know it's not even
wrong or a theorist will say
you know because you can't falsify it
but i i think
we're overwhelmed to use hoyle's word
and
vernacular kind of overwhelmed by popper
and uh and popper
is not gurdle in other words i i think
girdle
said something that's quantitative and
not just qualitative it is qualitative
but it's mostly quantitative
you can say what the limits of a
particular field of human endeavor
is or are and uh but in physics you know
falsifiability is not
uh is not the cinequan non nor did
popper actually say he was a big fan of
the st of the steady state theory as you
know
well yeah okay or had the virtue of
falsifiability well i think that
there's different levels of fossil
viability the question is not
can you falsify theory the question is
is it in principle falsifiable and those
are two different things i think yeah so
in principle
in principle you can imagine string
theory being falsifiable
i mean you know you can imagine somehow
doing experiments that might
be able to test a prediction if they
ever made one of
of uh of the early universe
um that uh so it's it's not falsifiable
now in the sense that first of all it
really doesn't yet make predictions
and secondly the scale of those at which
its predictions will be involved in
generally are beyond the
realm of our experimental ability right
now but that doesn't that's that's a
different level
of something that's than falsifiability
and the question
you know the question i used to ask is
inflation ever
falsifiable and and and i used to think
the answer was no but i i don't think
it's the case now
well let's get into that i mean i have
said that inflation could have been
falsified if we measured the curvature
to be
you know point nine zero which we
couldn't no no you know you see you're
too young that's a problem
you see you you you you you've seen a
problem before but yeah but
yeah well anyways um it's a problem now
and but
happily it's a problem you're gonna
quickly get over anyway um
but uh or not quickly but eventually
i'll get over it um
and that is that
that's why i used to say it wasn't
falsifiable because the minute
when i and then all the before 19 before
we wrote the paper on the cosmological
dark energy the conventional wisdom
at that time in the early 90s of
uh of of uh astronomers and cosmologists
and these these are the the the
non-particle cosmologists
was it the universe was open that the
the curvature you know
that that yeah
and that was the conventional wisdom and
in that picture
there were a million inflationary models
that would produce an open universe
so the minute that the data showed that
all of the theorists would immediately
develop inflation models which i thought
were incredibly ugly but i think most
many inflationary models are ugly
um which would make it open universe and
the point is you could you could design
an inflationary
model that would that was what my
concern was you could
design an inflationary model that would
predict an open universe or a flat
universe
and and potentially even a closed
universe haven't thought about the
details but
but and that bothered me because then
i'd say well if we measure making one
and that's all
if that's the only parameter we have
which at that time
we thought even that would be a stretch
even that
even that would be a stretch to be able
to measure that but if we could measure
that it wouldn't prove inflation
happened
it would just make it plausible but you
but inflation wouldn't be disproved if
omega wasn't one if there was curvature
and
that used to bother me and and um and of
course now people don't have to worry so
much about that because the
dark energy has saved the day it was one
of the reasons that mike turner
argued it was there among other reasons
um because it allows a flat universe
if but one in which matter doesn't
dominate
yeah anyway that would have falsified so
you're saying that would have been
a falsification of inflation more
generically than curvature not being
equal to zero no no neither of them
would have been a falsification
none of those things could falsify
inflation what i'm saying is that
looking at curvature
is not a falsification of inflation
because you could design inflationary
models
that will allow that will the at the end
of inflation you'll have curvatures so i
wanted to just read to you a statement
that i got from cameron vapha when he
was on the show
i asked him i said come run you know one
of the knocks against string theory is
that it
it doesn't have um you know it doesn't
make predictions that are testable
and therefore uh cannot be cannot be
falsified and then he went into the
black hole
entropy that it can be reproduced to
show the degrees of freedom that back in
in a two-dimensional black hole yeah in
a two-dimensional black hole
which we don't live in by the way
exactly right so i mentioned that and
then he said okay so i said come on
cameron
they said um so for example if you take
an electron
it has a mass and if you compute the
mass of the electron in the fundamental
units of physics which is planck mass
it's a very tiny mass in plank mass
something in the order of 10 to the
minus 23. it's a very tiny number so you
say great do we have any prediction
that the electron mass should have been
this small without knowing that there is
an electron
just by knowing that there is electric
charge and by knowing that there is dark
energy in the universe you find a bound
on the electron mass from string theory
you found that it's bounded fro on the
upper end by 10 to the minus one
and above 10 to the minus 31 on the
lower
end okay so lawrence what what do you
what do you make of that what would you
give cameron if you
takes your takes a club he's basically
saying the electron mass
is prediction it could have been 10 to
the minus 32
of the of the uh planck mass but it's
not it's between 10 minus 31 and 10 the
minus one
um a big range but it's a prediction it
could be wrong it could be falsified i
don't think it's
well look i don't think it's worth
getting hung up because the theory is
just so premature
that i'm not worried about his
predictions because i don't think i mean
what he's giving is just a dimensional
analysis argument which is fine it's
basically
if if you have if you have this if you
have the string coupling constant or the
planck mass
ultimately if you combine things you're
going to get some numbers
what saddens so it doesn't bother me
that string theory
hasn't i just think it's such an early
it's not it's not a well-defined theory
yet i think and i mean
it's got a lot of great ideas and maybe
it'll relate to the real universe at
some point
um it's as as i'd like to say and this
is a joke of frank's you know it's
promising but it's been promising and
promising for a long time
but um but but but what really
disappointed me the most to tell you the
truth is
the one thing if string theory had
predicted a cosmological constant
it would have been great but in fact not
only did it not predict a cosmological
constant but generally
it has a hard time even existing with
one and
and um without a negative one anyway and
um
yeah and so so and that's the one
i'm personally convinced that we won't
understand the energy of empty space
until we have a quantum theory of
gravity
i suspect they're intimately involved
with each other
and and so the one thing that i would
want a purported theory of quantum
gravity to tell me something about
would be the cosmological constant and
as far as i can tell neither string
theory nor for that matter loop quantum
gravity
have have had much of anything to say
about them and certainly didn't predict
them
generally find that that generally
string theory would tell would suggest
that what we're seeing now is a
temporary
aberration of will ultimately be a
negative uh
cosmological constant anyway
when uh i see a proliferation of of
anti-string theory not your
work necessarily books by peter white
sabine haasenfelder yeah yeah yeah
but i but let me make it pair i don't
think i've ever
yeah my book hiding in the mirror is
anything if anything it's a
um i came i wrote that book to praise
string theory not to bury it
right so but but you do hear uh these
crimes that
string theory is effectively sucking the
oxygen out of physics departments and
that i don't know it used to be more i
think it was it wasn't
it's certainly there's no doubt it was
in the 1990s
it was but i think the re you know what
happens it's the wonderful thing about
rats in a sinking ship
is that is that um is the the minute
the minute there was the possibility of
new experimental data either at the
large hadron collider
or in the universe what you saw i mean
there's a certain subgroup that were
lost forever to physics
and i used to see them when i was a
caltech i gave a colloquium once at cal
tech and
and it was my it was when ed whitton was
being courted there and as they say he
was a friend of mine and we had lunch
and then right before the colloquium i
was with another friend of mine uh
mark wise and and uh we were walking
towards building and all of the young
strength theorists were leaving
and and it was right before my cloakum
and mark said they never come to
physical okay because for them
physics is you know just it's just
something way below the plank scale and
it's not of interest it's not it's like
you know it's like botany
and and so for them everything that was
relevant for what you would normally
call physics was not interesting
there was a subclass of people who felt
that way that you know if it was
below the playing scale it really wasn't
interesting but what happened is for the
bulk of for the many
for many young people
who were not lost the minute there was
experimental evidence
or of anything interesting everyone
started to think about that so you had
string theorists start thinking about
cosmology or
or or or the higgs particle or other
things that
and so um so but it did for a while
skew seriously and as chair of the
physics department
at that time i was very aware of it it
seriously skewed
the appointment of young faculty and and
and and the and the ability of young
people to get jobs in physics that
weren't string theorists
and that was sad that was uh unfortunate
again you're lucky that you didn't
weren't in that generation that's right
um but again then i have uh people like
michio kaku coming on and saying no
because i asked him i was like where in
string theory does one find the muon g
minus two anomaly
where do i find the large hadron
collider beauty results these anomalies
and so forth where do i find hubble
tension
and he says it's all there and i said
what do you mean he says you just have
to tell me
the vacuum state and i say well why is
it my job as an experimentalist to tell
you what the vacuum state is of your
theory
and yet on the same token the swampland
et cetera
it seems hopeless lawrence and and i'm
wondering why is it that that you get
so much attention from people like you
know kaka with the god equation
and stephen hawking even talking about m
theory as if it's proven as if
off because it sounds profound and
everyone wants the next best thing
then you know after einstein and and and
steven i think i mean to his credit
he may have talked about those things
but but his work was
generally you know calculational and
involve things that you might
be able to at least in principle predict
um but and and relevant obviously black
hole evaporation is profoundly important
um i i frankly do have a problem with
misho kaku and he knows that i've been
i've done it many years ago at this
radio program we've been on
programs together but i think he
he inappropriately he misleads people
about string theory and i don't and i
and i have
and i and i don't uh i do
you know i don't look whenever i'm
talking about science
i'm sure i lead to misconceptions to
people but i don't knowingly
lead to misconceptions i try not to
knowingly
swindle people and i'm not saying he's
just flindler but i believe that
that people that knowingly statements
are made that are
that i think are not justified and
and and and it is true he's but he's
absolutely writing principle
if string theory were a theory of
of of uh of space and time
then obviously in some level
and if there and a complete theory that
from which all the forces of nature were
derivable
then obviously it's in there because
every you know
if it really were a theory of all the
forces nature then all the things we
measure must be a part of that
so so it's a tautology almost so of
course in principle it's there
but we don't but first of all a we don't
know how to do it but
more importantly than that we don't know
if it is we don't know if it
if this incredibly fascinating area of
mathematical physics
is a fundamental description of our
universe or rather it whether it's a
mathematical tool that allows us to
understand many other areas in physics
and that's the most important question i
don't really care about
at this point whether it makes
predictions that you could test because
i i think that's we're way away from
that
the question we really have to address
is that there's no evidence yet
that it is a theory that that
that string theory describes
uh our universe right
okay so i guess i and i i wanna i'm
we're gonna go off of
uh kaku in a second but um but i did ask
him one thing i said if you were the
um you know president of the national
science foundation you have a portfolio
and you have to balance your portfolio
how would you say the portfolio should
be balanced given that there is you know
tremendous
over-investment to some people's minds
into string theory and
you know dramatic under-investment in
new models like stephen wolfram's model
um eric weinstein has the geometric
unity proposal
uh and uh and and of course twister
theory and so forth
so how do you balance the proposal now i
made you you know uh director of the nsf
what do you do lawrence you can it's
fine to say that a thousand flowers
bloom as yeah
as the you know individual once said um
but how do you balance your portfolio
and well given that what you
i mean look you do is peer review i
think you you you know
and you have to look first of all by the
way
it doesn't really matter because it's in
the the costs
of of string theory or i mean by the way
compared to the other things you said
string theory is on a wholly different
level compared to the other
ideas you talked about i mean it's not
really fair to put string through the
level of
those other other left field things you
talked about but string theory is really
well motivated from a fundamental
direction
but they're they're let they're the
xeroxing costs
associated with the large advert
collider i mean they're just in the
noise
you could you know they're in fact by
the way
that's the way it's normally done when i
was at harvard
the theory group the only reason the
theory group was funded
was because they were combined with the
experimental particle
group so that basically the they were
getting the
the the breadcrumbs that were that was
being thrown out by the
quiz because experiments are so
expensive theory itself is pretty cheap
but nevertheless what you have to do at
some level and
is broadly
have groups within within physics assess
what are more
likely or less likely and i do think
it's really important to fund
a variety of options but as as
as the editor and the publisher of the
new york times once said and i've quoted
actually he wasn't the first one to say
this i've since learned but he used to
say um as
salzburger once said yeah i like to keep
an open mind but not so hoping that my
brains fall out
right ultimately you you it's reasonable
to fund things but you've got it but but
they
but they have to fall within some range
of that the community views as
realistic well motivated well-defined
and
um and i don't think um
so when it comes to particle physics um
particle theory
there was a time when when when um
when i think string theory is probably
getting the line share of money and
people who weren't doing string theory
complain
but to be fair it was so attractive that
you
generally had the most cape men the most
capable
young theorists working on it
and so it was attractive enough to drive
maybe these people were voting with
their feet
so look you know it's always a hard
thing it's you're
it's like asking first of all it's not a
zero-sum game
right it's like when people say we
should we fund the large iron collider
or should we fund
erasing poverty and and the point is
it's not one or the other
okay and if it were we'd be in a really
sad situation
um it's not wonder and so i think that
what you can do
is you can if there's a lot of
interesting intellectual work going you
might get expand the pot
or if there isn't you might contract and
and
frankly there have been times
over the last 25 years when i've often
thought we
probably are funding uh particle theory
um
too much because there wasn't much of
interest going on in that area and it's
an attractive nuisance and that there
aren't you know there's
as few spots to become faculty in the
high energy in any academic
we had a search last year but before
covid we had 400 applicants for once
yeah i mean well listen i remember when
the superconducting supercollider was
canceled i
that was the year before i became
chairman the chairman at case and i was
i moved there because i was given 13 new
faculty slots to build an apartment and
and i'm very proud of what it did there
but but within
within three weeks i got 200
applications from from experimentalists
from the from the superconducting
superplayer all of whom were really good
experimentalists many of whom would
stake their careers on this
had left their jobs at 10-year jobs at
other institutions and now had no
options and i couldn't hire any of them
because the point was
you know what can they what are they
what are they going to work on you know
i mean i if i were it was different i
was trying to grow a department and i
had to hire people who were going to
have an
impact on an emerging field because they
had to be very strategic there
if i were harvard i could always hire an
extra
experimentalist in that regard because i
didn't need it to to
but but it's it there is there are so
few people as you say who get jobs in
universities and i have
concerns about how about how that
process goes one
the main thing ultimately and i this was
my guide when i was a
of a chair and so i didn't care if
someone was a string theorist or not
whenever i've been on a search committee
my feeling is
you always hire the best person namely
the most capable
intellect who may be doing something now
but yet the point is physics evolves
so even if they're what they're working
on now is interesting in three years it
may not be
so you hire someone who you think will
be able to move with the field
and continue to be a force and there and
and so i think that's
ultimately because i believe in
meritocracy
i think academia should be a meritocracy
that should be the only requirement that
comes in ultimately
that comes down to things and then and
then you
it doesn't really matter the field that
people are working in it's how
it's their quality of their intellect in
a way that matters more than
than anything else so we'll get to
meritocracy
and uh and science and elsewhere i just
want to remind people i'm talking with
dr lawrence krauss author of many books
including his most recent book which we
have yet to get to the physics of
climate change a universe from nothing
the greatest story ever told
uh uh adam ali's physics of star trek
he is the proprietor of the origins uh
podcast
which is uh a must listen to i've
poached many of his guests
he's also a director founder of the
origins project foundation
uh which i'll put links to in the show
notes um
but the last thing i want to say just
before we move from uh really the hard
science the big picture questions
i i've started to think a lot lawrence
about you know how i can
rekindle a little bit of that you know a
milli or a nano
galileo and and recreate what he called
the assayer
el sagittari and and that was to like
what does an assayer do an assayer
doesn't own any gold but he has a rock
and he takes
what is purported to be gold and he rubs
it on the rock and
in so doing he provides value of untold
potentially untold wealth or
he crushes the dreams of people that
thought that they got this gold from
their
you know great and uncle or whatever so
that's what he did that's what an
assailer does
i'm wondering are we missing things now
people tell me to test my theory
um you know stephen wolfram is on my
podcast he's talking about uh bronchial
space
and this this uh bronchial not like your
chest but brunch branching space and and
and sort of how you could test it and it
would require
you know it could actually be falsified
but it requires you know advanced
lisa or what i i just i was thinking and
i said to him
i said you know what if you tell me you
need this future collider okay there's
no target there's nothing natural but
bigger is always better and what if i
said to you like 10 years ago i'm going
to give you
something that can crash two um two
atoms
two nuclei together and they each have
10 to the 58th neutrons
and i'm going to crash them together at
half the speed of light would that test
your theory of everything in other words
we have phenomenal
you know energy scales accessible to us
why aren't we are we missing something
you know newton as you talk about in
uh in a uh you know i'm sorry the um
the greatest story ever told you talk
about how he was right
uh about uh light you know he proved
that light
going through two prisms was not
diminished any more than going through
one prism right
and i was thinking he proved the color
theory of light in a lot of ways and
that is a quantum at some level would be
something that feynman would would have
recommended in other words what low
energy phenomena
are we perhaps overlooking because we
always have this bigger better
greater farther faster higher energy
frontier to pursue
well look you're not alone and i don't
think um
a lot of people and in particular myself
and mental work
over the years that frank wilchick and i
when we worked together have been worked
on
have been looking at ways to use
there are two extremes of physics
there's extreme there's the energy
frontier but there's also the
sensitivity frontier
and in the atomic physics domain
but sensitivities are achievable now
with with
with not you could call them tabletop
they're not really tabletop but they're
they're not lhc scale experiments maybe
most of them occupy a single room or two
and you can achieve sensitivities
looking for things at one part and 10 to
the 18th
sometimes 10 to the 20th and so the
question of course
is there's two ways to detect
new physics setup new fundamental
physics by fundamental i mean
associated with the fundamental forces
of nature not you know i don't want to
make have this big argument about
whether
you know what's fundamental but no i
agree yeah but
one is by probing directly
those scales and because of quantum
mechanics to probe physicists don't
build
bigger machines because they want to
spend money you need quantum mechanics
says the more energy you have the
smaller the
the the regime you can resolve with your
microscope
it's just that simple the this this if
you want to think of it the smaller the
wavelength of your probe
and the wavelength goes inversely with
energy um the more you can
probe matter on smaller smaller scales
so we have to build bigger
accelerators to to detect things on
smaller scales
but the other way that phenomena at
small scales can be manifested
is by very very weak effects
at macroscopic scales and so
you are a a very interesting and it's an
area that's growing all the time is to
look at ways that we might use
ultra-sensitive experiments
to probe for very rare processes or very
weak
effects that might might be new and so
you know that that's a that's a a
vibrant area of physics and one which
i've
run a meeting at several meetings about
one which i've worked on
the one the last papers i wrote was on
exactly using lasers
uh atomic clocks to try and probe for
something called axions
because i'm fascinated i actually came
up with that idea what i was giving
as as you know because i came to
ucsd to to give this math lecture i've
for many years i gave you know more
public lectures at a number of meetings
and
this one was a metrology meeting in
france and they wanted a
a cultural talk on cosmology if you wish
and so i was there
and then i and then after my big talk
which
opened the meeting i i listened
to the talks and of course a lot of it
was was highly technical
but i told myself i you know i i should
try and make the most of this and
and it was there when i began to
appreciate the incredible
power of metrology and and atomic clocks
and and and
to be able to probe things so so that i
think you know and the point is
you never know if you're missing
something right the all you can do is
try and
and this is what i was going to say to
you about the national science
foundation and i know
the director of national science fiction
was worked with me at my old university
um
ultimately what people don't realize a
theory we talk all about these theories
but physics is an empirical science
all of science is empirical and what
should drive the science is experiments
not
theory and generally that's what does
happen so that's where the money should
generally go
the amount of money that should go into
theory should always be a small factor
compared to the amount of money that
goes to experiment and so
my feeling has always been that you
should do the experiments you can do
and whenever you have come up with a new
technique it's worth exploring it
because you never know where it's going
to lead
and people always say what to me what's
the next big thing
and i always say the same thing if i
knew i'd be doing it right
okay so so we obviously are missing
things because that's why experiments
surprise us and that's why we
and and i as often say i'm i'm i'm
surprised every day and i'm
and some days i'm surprised that i'm not
surprised um
when i hear new results so so we keep
opening up new windows on the universe
and that will guide our understanding of
the universe not
generally not what what theorists do
theorists provide
you know a framework and they're they're
clear counter examples where theory has
has changed our world view galileo was
an example and obviously einstein was
another
but but generally it works the other way
around and people don't realize that
and and one thing i've you know been
curious about is
why are there so many uh popular science
popularizations popularizers how
everyone say it uh dating back to
you know to newton and to einstein
and uh you know i actually have one doll
so i've got carl sagan
here's carl sagan here's galileo you saw
him i'm not sure newton was a
popularizer by the way newton was
detested to pop
publicly i do have one finger puppet
and here's einstein over here i think i
have that same set okay go ahead
but then but then i have one that's been
a guest on my podcast and that's
that's gnome okay there we go that's
great so yeah
maybe we'll get a kraus doll but um but
i'm going to ask you once don't start
sticking needles in and i'm fine
well they go on my thumb yeah okay
anyway um
i don't want to go there but go on yeah
that's right yeah exactly um
the question i have is why are so many
why is there such a surface of
of popularizers of theoretical physics
either brian green
you lisa randall janet levin uh katy
free you know
there's so so many and there's almost
nobody who's an experimentalist like me
and because serious sex let's face it
theory is sexier
it really is because it's the hype no
but it's also the tradition i mean
the of the of the lone scientists
sitting in the room late at night
thinking about the universe and and
and it's so easy to make hypotheses
about grand hypotheses where if you're
an experimentalist you actually have to
do something
and the devil if you're an
experimentalist is in the details as you
well know
yeah with with uh with the experiments
you've worked on
and and and so and that's not what tends
to get
press because the press generally
you know just reproduce the press
releases of the
of of the people writing books and and
um and and that doesn't get
captured in people's imaginations and
it's sad because i actually have tried
in my books
very carefully to to point out the
experimental basis of things because it
really is the heart of science
but but i think it's just that it's the
reason i became a theorist it's sexier
you know i was an experimentalist i
worked at i mean when i was an
undergraduate i worked in
in in summers in in in projects that
have
high energy projects and it you know i'd
spend
and then during the year i had part-time
jobs i'd spent eight months trying to
fix a what was then you know what's
called a spark chamber and you know and
then just
i mean the trip things that would occupy
me for a long time that would
take forever to do almost nothing and it
certainly turned me
off but that's but i admire tremendously
now now that i'm older i certainly
almost feel
wistful that i i because i find i mean
i've been now involved i've seen for the
last 30 years i've proposed experiments
many of which are being done
and i'm wistful and for the first time
actually part of an experimental
collaboration but
but i'm almost wistful that i'm not
experimentals because the difference
between a theorist and experimentalist
is that
an experimentalist actually does
something i mean has something to show
for what they've done whereas a theorist
has has you know just has ideas
and there's no priority really on ideas
and though we always try and
try and have that and and and and it's
just
my respect for experiment has increased
exponentially from the time
i graduate in fact when i was to be fair
when i was an undergraduate i did two
degrees
one in mathematics and one in physics
the reason i did that at my university
was it got me out of an experimental
class
okay that's i mean it wasn't the only
reason it was to me it seemed the most
challenging
option at the university i was at and i
so i decided to do it but
but one of the many virtues of it was
that i didn't i i was i
i opted out of the experimental class
and that and
and sadly now i wish um not that we
should have done it but but i i think
people don't appreciate because we all
talk about it i mean you and i have been
talking about that because these ideas
are fascinating
and there's something that people can
relate to without knowing details of
statistics or diodes or
i mean and and and so um
even though there's incredible
intellectual baggage that really is
required to get any kind of adequate
understanding of theory you can build it
up in a way that but i think to to
really
understand that the guts of an
experiment requires a lot more
intellectual baggage that very few
people are willing to
to carry to get there my late
uh father used to say that uh to be an
experimentalist
you actually have to know the theory at
least as well as a beginning grad
student or so you don't have to come up
with new theories that's not a
requirement that i put on my
experimental
graduate students but you should at
least be concerned you know conversion
in it
unless you just want to be a technician
there's nothing wrong with technicians
we need them
uh but but if you're not going to think
about the big picture and i wonder
lawrence is that
i find you know i make a joke people are
like why are you doing this podcast
you know it's just to make the tons of
money that youtube sends us every month
for a creator
no you know and i say actually why i'm
doing it is because
uh on my day job which is to you know
co-construct the simon's ray the simon's
observatory
it is uh usually involving people i have
to talk to in other words it's people
you know and it's and it's very long
term i mean we won't complete the
observatory of the array you know it
takes decade
you know to complete these experiments
they go on for decades but a podcast is
kind of instant gratification i i can
talk to people i want to talk to not the
you know plumber that's you know telling
me that there's this leak in this freon
thing and that's 17 000 feet and i might
have to get on a plane
but instead it's you know people i want
to talk to and not that i don't you know
like those people it's just i
it's a it's a drain there's a lot of uh
experimental uh physics is sitting
around
bored and then terrified when something
doesn't work uh but
uh but i wonder is that partially why
you started your podcast is that to get
the instant gratification of talking to
some of the world's leading
intellectual lights well
look podcast i've been doing i i well
first of all
i'm fortunate because my field allows me
instant gratification right
i mean there are two types of theories
there's some theorists who work
on one thing for 30 years and i don't
want to put that down anyway because
it's very important
but i've always i've worked in
everything from geophysics to
to to you know to to black hole physics
to
to some mathematical physics to you know
and so for me i love
you know i get instant gratification by
learning a new thing and working on it
and then
and then i go away which you know which
which actually i've talked to frank
about this
strategically is not so good because
when you write the first paper on a
subject by the end
in 20 years that no it's never
referenced anymore because everyone's
always
unless you continue to write papers on
but that doesn't matter and
so so i already get a lot of as a
theorist i can get quick gratification
that way
but it's more no it's it's deeper in the
sense that um
first of all i've been doing this for a
long time uh with my
with even before the i i created the
origins project at the last university
even
at um even a case i'd built up
an effort to try and bring different
people from different areas together
because i find that that symbiotic
relationship between knowledge at all
levels interesting
but then i expanded it i mean then it
was still mostly what you would call
academics
um but but but then what at what what
for me
was the driving factor is that i believe
science is part of our culture
not that i believe it's science is part
of our culture it should be more
integrated in our culture and that means
it's cultural and therefore for me
it's a matter of bringing people from
all aspects of culture together and i'm
fortunate
and so and and you've been fortunate by
poaching but um
but i'm fortunate that for some reason
or that i realized when i was doing the
origins thing
that i had a very broad rolodex if you
want to call it that of people
of significance in in hollywood in in
different areas of
of of academics and in even politics and
journalism
it just happened over time because i've
been involved in a long time it just it
wasn't any planning
and so i thought
we discovered i read large panels but
then we discovered that one-on-one
dialogues
were fascinating and i did one with uh
early on with trump's comment
alda and i did one with uh uh um
um uh johnny depp
and and others and that that people are
fascinated by
being a fly in the wall and as one of my
public
my my um my editors once said people
want to go to the horse's mouth
and so what they want to hear are the
people that they want to hear from
and so my feeling was if i could get
them together but not just some
superficial thing
to create a dialogue that would be
different
that would be the kind of thing they
could people couldn't hear
about everything that that person was
thinking put in perspective and which is
why i tried to prepare so much for all
of my
the podcast that that that would be
something that people might like and it
would also
frankly archivally serve a very useful
purpose because in the future people
will have that
to work from but but but it but
but you're right in one sense and this
is the sense that i think all
people don't realize why people do
science
most things i do because i do because i
want because they make me happy
right and most scientists aren't
scientists because they want to save the
world even if they're saving the world
it's because it makes them happy they
like what they're doing
and the and you're absolutely right the
podcast gave me an excuse
to go around the world and have in-depth
dialogues with people who i may have had
as friends
generally but in-depth dialogues that i
wouldn't have had otherwise
and and so really in some sense of
course it's for me even though i think
it provides a more useful purpose
yeah so some of the uh eight other nobel
prize winning guests that weren't
influenced by you that i've had on my
show for the same reason i've written a
new book that's coming out in september
just distilling those conversations into
chunks of actionable information it's
called think like a nobel prize winner
because i felt like it would be a shame
if a as you said there wasn't archived
b the transcripts are kind of you know
meandering and it's hard to keep as you
know as a host
and a guest and and when i'm meandering
just now uh you're getting an in-depth
class on that but uh but i wanted to
distill it into
chunks of actionable information and and
some of the things were really inspired
by
things that surprised me from the guests
in other words i talked to
barry barrish and i said barry you know
i one of my audience members asked me
asked me you know like
do you ever have the imposter syndrome
ever in your past life
and he said what are you talking about
my past life i feel it now
more than ever yeah sure and uh vignette
that you and david gross spoke about
last week uh on your pocket and when
they win their nobel prizes they have to
go up and sign this ledger
that says yes i received my my medallion
you know barry left us here
in the couch yeah when he was visiting
but um but uh
you have to sign his ledger and it's
impossible not to be curious about who
came before you and he looks through it
he sees fine men
okay miriam mayor we'll get to in a
second um and then he gets to this guy
it gets uh to albert and he said i've
never felt more
dramatically inadequacy um uselessness
and
and imposter syndrome well and i said
yeah go ahead
well now why are you finished and then
and then i'll jump in well i said you
know what i did some research barry uh
and that's actually what inspired me to
actually take his
words and put it into a book with along
with the eight other laureates including
frank
shelly and many others but um but i said
you know what
uh barry you know who else had imposter
syndrome einstein
he thought newton was the greatest
intellect the greatest contributor
lawrence
to western culture einstein called
newton and you know who newton of course
uh worshipped more than anybody and
before whom felt the imposter syndrome
lawrence do you know who that was
what scientist that was was it galileo i
don't know
no jesus christ yeah i was going to say
jesus christ yeah i was going to say
because he didn't
yeah i should have known the answer
because there's no human that
no real human that that newton would
have felt uh subservient to in any way
um so yeah i wanna i wanna get that uh
get you were gonna say something when i
uh
look
it's easy to how can i say this in a way
that's
that sounds right
if you ever achieve a level of fame at
some level celebrity and
and for one reason another because of
whatever i've done in some level i
have have you realized that
you them and this is what i think a lot
of noble lawyers have to come to grips
with because until they win the nobel
prize they
i mean in the community in their own
community they're well known but they
don't they're not well known outside
their community
and then and then frankly they're not
that well known outside the community
afterwards just a little blip but
but um you
have to not believe the press clippings
because every plus clipping there's no i
mean if you're a theory if when i when i
go give a talk or
when i see anyone and anyone else
they're always presented as you know
when i see a blurb in the book
as the next einstein the next blah blah
blah blah and
and it is really easy when that's
happening
because you know you're not to get that
imposter syndrome you know you know
hey i'm being described as something i
know i'm not
and maybe i'm just a complete fraud
anyway and i mean i think i i think
anyone
i certainly have felt that many times
and people say rightly
but but um but uh uh
i think it's if if you don't probably
then you suffer from the donning krueger
syndrome because
because um i mean
it's part of the problem i mean you you
know
how can i say this again to you losing
nobel prize
there's this fixation on nobel prizes in
the first book in the second booklet
that
is is unfortunate away because first of
all
i've known almost every nobel prize
winner in physics of my time anyway and
and
and in many other fields as well
probably no 50 nobel prize winner maybe
more
um but you know it's it's just it's just
a prize and suddenly it
instills this stuff and and it you know
it it's for work
it's and the person you suddenly the
person who won the nobel prize is seen
as some
is elevated to some level when it's the
work and the person
may or may not be worthy of of
of being elevated that level they did
some work it may have been an accident
it may have been other things
right look at fritz haber
as a society the public tends to label
nobel laureates as if there's something
special
i think it's a form of religion it's a
form of almost yeah but but in in
general
it's it's really recognizing work and
you know that was one thing
speaking of philosophy because i used to
read a lot of philosophy and ancient
history when i was
younger and i almost went when i almost
took a road scholarship at oxford i was
gonna do physics and philosophy
thankfully i didn't
do that but um but uh i
um the the ancient greeks and romans
were really quite different they
separated
the work from the artist and so they
they revered the work but they but they
didn't revere the artist they would
basically say you know well let's you
know they thought it was a divine
inspiration and that
this person had had ha but more or less
it just happened to be the vessel of the
gods
but but uh but it was like yeah big deal
and and so and we've gone the opposite
direction in some sense and and it's a
culture of
uh cult of celebrity we live in and and
uh
and so we because of that
uh i would suspect that many people um
after getting great adulation and
recognition
most people of who who are who are at
all self-critical
wonder you know ask themselves am you
know or quickly realize they shouldn't
believe they're blessed clippings
yeah yeah except for frank when i talked
to frank i said did you ever have the
impostor syndrome he said no
it was basically the opposite and yeah
well frank i've known
yeah i've known it for 40 years yeah he
had to uh
wait for you know 30 something years
until he actually received it and then
i thought that would be excruciating but
yeah i mean it was excruciating let me
tell you i don't know what frank said
but i've lived with it okay every year
for i'm sorry frank yeah every year
frank and i would have this call
because we were extremely close friends
and he i think
wouldn't talk too many people about it
it's hard if you think it's it
it's hard and what you shouldn't and the
point is you shouldn't fixate on it but
it becomes harder on her i was very very
happy
not only because the work deserved it
and i actually was a nominator for the
nobel prize and that was one of the
things i had nominated but
in fact everyone i ever nominated for
nobel prize by the way won one but
anyway
um not that but it may have taken 10
years for that to happen but
but um um it
it will it relieved a kind of tension
that could have
that for some people it could it could
really hurt their
them as scientists and and and and their
personalities no no that's that's what i
wanted to dispel one
in my first book you know it was written
from the perspective of someone who was
told when he was hired
that he was hired because he thought
they the chairman who his father
nikolai bassoff had won the 1964 nobel
prize
for the laser he said we hired you and
we're only going to give you tenure if
we think you're on a
short track to a nobel prize and even
after bicep two
people say things like this and i just
think it's it's a charade in a sense
because
you know again we should venerate the
people i actually think
that the people are more impressive than
the institution a lot of
a lot of the prestige of the nobel prize
has come because of the people that have
been awarded it and i think it's
interesting when you think about
how uh you know how society is sort of
venerating this and by the way you
mentioned the dunning-kruger effect
i just want to point out that i am you
know perhaps the world's greatest expert
in the dunning-kruger
because i studied it for a little bit um
to meritocracy which will
well let me let me just say one thing i
think yeah
i i i don't want to focus on nobel prize
too much but i've been
strongly involved in in in following it
and
as i see nominating and then at the at
the nobel prize ceremonies
um and and one of the things that amazes
me
no it doesn't amaze me it's the reason
the other all the other there's a
profusion of prizes
and i remember when fred cavalli talked
to me early on and was at the nobel
ceremonies with me once when he was
trying to emulate it with this cavely
prizes
i said fred don't waste your money it's
never going to be a nobel prize but
the difference is and
it's a waste of time but these people
are willing to do it that
they spend a full year they spend
a year the minute the day the nobel
prize announced they meet the next day
starting for the next year
and what's amazing is they could have
blown it so many times
and generally have now there are a
million people who deserve the nobel
prize they didn't get it
but there aren't that many people who
got it who didn't deserve it there are
some
and by that i mean not as people but i
meant the but the work
and they do an incredible job of vetting
it which is why all these other prizes
are so
subjective and peripheral they just sort
of throw names in a hat and they and
they and it and that's why
one of the many reasons i just think
they're far too many prizes
in science but um but i will say that
they they've generally done a good job
and it is surprising
on the whole given that
the work is what one's the prize not the
person
that remarkably but not completely but
remarkably
a large number of people who won the
nobel prize are also really good
scientists
not everyone yeah but but but it's
amazing
that correlation is kind of um it's kind
of
good and i do think that that adds at
least that history
at least adds something to that to the
village
but but but you know but my friend
martin reese is totally opposed to the
nobel prize oh no he hates it yeah well
you know i mean he's right now that this
notion of three people
is just kind of silly in science yeah
all the laureates rail against that that
i've interviewed well after they win
it's easy it's easy anyway
i don't see you like turning it down you
know all the nobel prizes except for
uh chemistry and physics have been
rejected by it yeah i know i wouldn't
i'd take the templeton prize
if they gave it to me i'd take the money
and then i and i badmouth the prize but
i take the money
that's what i say i say if you want to
find out if keating's a hypocrite just
get me the nobel prize and see if i turn
it down
yeah but but turning now to that topic
and also your celebrity your prolific uh
following twitter
elsewhere you've got half a million or
so followers etc
um you know there's a line in uh animal
farm
where the pig talks to benjamin the
donkey and the pig says
um ben you got this long tail
it's so beautiful you're so lucky and
benjamin the donkey says yeah
the good lord gave me a tail to swat
away the flies
but to be honest i'd rather not have the
flies
and not need the tail all right do you
want do you want
you wish you had a pig like tail or do
you wish you didn't need a tail
uh that you have uh or you know the kind
of fame attention celebrity
criticism it's it look it's first of all
it happens right so it doesn't seem to
me that i mean
there are good things and they're bad
things and i've gotten to do many things
that i would never have been able to do
otherwise i mean tremendous
and including many of the people i know
that i would never know otherwise
so it's from a personal perspective it's
been wonderful
especially in modern times if you have
any celebrity it's it's it
it's also awful um
i would like to think
that i wasn't driven by that but i
also realistic enough to know that that
i probably
you know at some level
probably craved some some attention um
we all do but i you know so so i know
but i think that
i like to think i did what i i've done
what i've done because i think it's
worth doing and i've been on the whole i
would say i've been pleased
by the opportunities that i've had and
moreover it's not a choice i guess
that's the bottom line
i did what i've done not because i chose
to do it i didn't have a choice
i i i
just like about surrounding physics i'm
i'm interested in a lot of different
things and i'm
from a personal perspective what a
i guess a traditional academic in that
sense academia itself has never
been been enough to lure my soul
interests
and so in fact when i one of the reasons
i
you know when i talk about physics and
philosophy i one of the reasons i
hesitated about doing a phd in physics
was because i'm very political and i'm
very interested in people and and the
kind of physics i was interested in had
nothing to do with people
and it turned out i was a but there was
no plan
it turned out i was able to mesh those
two things my interest in science my
interest in people
because of the popularizations i got
involved in but it wasn't
there are some people i know who are
very systematic
in this regard my friend um neil
degrasse tyson is incredibly systematic
so life he knew
what he wanted what he wanted to achieve
and what he had to do to achieve it
and in my case i just basically it's an
accident but i knew i do know that if i
i didn't really have a choice i think if
i hadn't
been writing and speaking i probably
wouldn't have been
have been able to focus on physics and
if i hadn't been able to do physics
well enough to be able to achieve some
level of
of whatever the word is credibility i
guess
um then i wouldn't have had the
opportunity to to do the writing and
speaking so
i think it it wasn't a choice anyway
and there are a lot of people that you
know whenever i want to damn one of my
guests with faint praise you've
got some new theory about something i'll
say they know the history of physics
really well
like because you can get away with a lot
if you just like spew
you know kind of historical platitudes
and then throwing a
an equation or two uh but you know like
you know i'm going to interrupt you
again
one of the reasons i love writing books
and i've written a lot and i guess i'm
on my 12th now but um
is is that in your hands show me your
hands laurence what are you writing now
i think you're writing something right i
i i i am but i can't
i can't show you my hands because i'll
it's like poker
um but uh but um
one of the things i like about it is
that i is is well i learn a tremendous
amount
but i also learned history because you
can spout in fact just this morning when
i was writing working on a new book
actually i
i um i i read something i wrote and i
and i said is that really how it
happened and then i started to go back
and discover
what i've always said about is totally
wrong and and and so
when you put it on paper at least when i
do i don't know about other people
it seem it has a level of seriousness
which it doesn't have when you're just
lecturing or talking
and so i've been able to learn a
tremendous amount of history
um just by by writing about it because
uh
then if you write it about it's like
teaching i mean if you write about it
then you have to learn it
yeah but i think the contrast with what
you do and what i try to do
is you know there's different types of
content creators and there are those
that document what other people have
done
that are people that document what they
themselves have done i think the latter
is always more interesting to say you
know like
even to expose your own warts and
failures and flaws
and your thinking process in the wrong
turns because that's the problem i think
and i'm gonna get off the nobel prize i
promise but that we present you know
physics as done by nobel prize i mean my
freshman lab classes are
you know for them or you know nobel
prize winning experiment i used to do at
case western i would do the michaelson
morley experiment
and one day i'm always pleased to say i
had the chair that michaelson had when i
was
oh wow oh that's great that's great you
know that's that feynman had
uh so uh for other guests but i do say
you know it kind of distorts the way
that history is done it's not written
only
like it distorts the physics process it
doesn't distort history it's not lying
it's just that's not the way science
proceeds it proceeds via
millions of wrong turns and then finally
there's a path that that works the right
way
but i want to stick around simon
probably didn't work at his desk so it's
okay
that's right the strip club around the
corner anywhere else but this desk so it
doesn't really matter
anyway okay i want to turn now to uh
meta scientific questions and in
particular
my favorite books by the way is my book
on feynman quantum man yeah i'm gonna
put a link
on that book and and and actually you
know what you're proud of if you're a
member of audible
you can download that book for free so
that that is a free book that you can
get for if you're an audible member so i
can listen to it again and
i have oh good i can download it and
listen to it when you were here
uh you signed many copies of it from my
undergraduate who got the highest score
in my cosmology class so i gave away one
of those and i kept one
with your signature on it in the corner
over here in geoffrey burbridge's old
office
oh that's nice it was a labor of love
and and um
it was and you showed him there's a
famous picture of him with you
yeah yeah but yeah but you have long
sideburns you had mutton chops i think
at the top
well i had long hair a very long hair i
was young anyway
so uh the next kind of pivot if you have
time uh
i know uh uh you know i can keep talking
all day
as you know i'm a new yorker but i want
to ask you
certainly questions from my audience
i've got uh about
13 question my audience but before i go
there i want to talk about
uh something a term that i believe you
coined called the ideological corruption
of science
and i want to i want to be uh you know
kind of steel man against that so i'm at
uc san diego
which is the home of the late great
maria gephardt mayor
who once when she won the nobel prize in
1963
the la jolla or sorry the san diego
evening tribune
ran the following headline san diego
mother wins nobel prize and that's
really funny
until we realized that andrew lang's you
know widow ex-wife
francis arnold when she won the 2018
nobel prize the initial headline on jpl
i tweeted out and she responded to it
last week was mother of jpl
flight tech uh wins uh nobel prize and
kevin
she was laughing about she liked it
because it gave credit to herself anyway
um i'm here at ucsd we only have our
physics department named after maria
gephardt mayor because johns hopkins was
to uh
was too uh sexist to give it to her and
they would only give a position to her
husband
and so we uh we said we give a position
to you maria
and her husband and he kind of came
along as a spouse which happens a lot
nowadays
and back in the day of course you know
einstein was forbidden from winning a
nobel prize
when i hear uh folks like heather
mcdonald say on this podcast you know
what do you think that like uh physics
is systemically racist there are no
nobel prize winners
because systemic racism exists in the
nobel academy i said
heather do you think physics is time
translation and variant in other words
do you think the greatest minds of human
history
would have been the greatest minds in
any other generation and she said yeah
and i said well
a hundred years ago einstein there was a
meetings uh by uh
folks like the aryan chief of physics uh
you know
uh bert leonard and others that said no
way in hell is einstein getting a nobel
prize
and only he's getting it if he does
something related to non-jewish physics
so
i'll ask you lawrence what makes you
think that
nowadays not just the nobel prize but
hiring faculty decisions ten-year
decisions
post-docs graduate students all the way
up the gated inter uh you know the kind
of academic hunger games that i call it
um what makes you think that we're so
meritocratic and that that's actually
the best way to go about things
well well because again i i like
i'm an empiricist and einstein
um you you know you know who einstein
was right you actually talk about him
you have a puppet and all the rest in
spite of the fact that he was a jewish
physicist who
who um who uh uh
had problems at the time and the reason
was his work uh
ultimately he was able to he and his
work overcame it because that's the way
science works because
because science is a meritocracy
the problem i have is that of course
there are always biases
at any given time and and you're
absolutely right there's a time the
world is not time translation variant
but but i find it interesting because i
think in a piece
i think i don't know if i wrote it i
guess that i probably in that piece
for the wall street journal i wrote i
don't think i talked about that i think
i
may have talked about it in a companion
piece for coilette because it was i was
allowed to have longer
space but um when people talk about
systemic racism
first of all i've been chair i mean i've
been a chair of a physics department
i've been
i've been i've been in physics
departments and involved in hiring for a
long time
long enough time to know that um that if
anything
it's quite the opposite i mean i i the
craziness of
of of even the defining the way it was i
talk about in one of
my my my um articles that i
when i was chair of physics i tried to
hire a really good black physicist who
was
someone i know in respect of the
condensed matter physicist from uh
university of illinois uh at urbana who
was tenured and he wanted to come
um his wife was gonna come to case
actually as a
and and so he was gonna be a trailing
spouse and i
desperately tried to hire him and
and was not able to because he wasn't a
minority
he wasn't he was he was from he was from
uh bahamas i think
he was he was not african-american and
um and so that arbitrary definition was
just ridiculous but
but the example i used about what of
this problem of
of claiming systemic racism and and and
how
and how to resolve it was that was the
anti-semitism
of of the scientific community which not
only einstein dealt with but feynman dad
to deal with and i
used the example of feynman feynman was
applied to graduate school at princeton
and nearly didn't get in because the
basically
the head of the physics department said
you know how jewish is he
yeah and and and and talked to the
chairman of the physics department mit
who basically said he's not very jewish
you know and in looks or in in you know
whatever and so
he he they allowed him in okay but what
happened then
okay did they they didn't have to do a
quota for jews
what happened is feynman became the best
one of the best scientists of his kind
and then you have the next generation
you have steve
weinberg and shelly glacial and what
happened was
that that the jews who came into physics
not all of them but some of them became
the
excelled and became the leading
physicists of their day and that
anti-semitism just went away
because of the quality of their work it
was the quality of their work and their
quality of their
intellects that that that allowed them
to to
overcome what were real institutional
prejudices of the time institutional
prejudices which i would say
are much more explicit than any claimed
institutional prejudices against race
right now
okay i i i cannot imagine
nor would i have ever seen anyone saying
you know we can't have that person
because they're black it's it's just not
it's just not the way moreover
while anti-semitism was true in academia
it was true in society
racism is absolutely true in in in in
society as a it has been in the
as a as a part of america since it's
since its creation
and it's a reality but the way to cure
any quote problems of diversity is not
to cure them at the level of a professor
that's just too late because again and
heather i don't know whether heather's
talked about this but i know other
people have
the people you're you're hiring are
already very privileged
in general most of them have gone to
first-rate undergraduate schools and
graduate schools
and and and it no it's not really
diverse okay
where you have to where we have to
confront problems of
diversity and inequity is it is at the
social level is that i
i lived in cleveland you you were there
as a graduate and
cleveland was a was a was a travesty
when you were there and when i came
there the inner city of cleveland
was a problem and i went into inner city
schools in cleveland my wife at the time
work
volunteered in them and i saw that the
the what these young kids had to
overcome
the cleveland didn't have a a tax base
so these kids
in the schools weren't getting textbooks
so when i was chair of physics
department i we
i made a point of saying okay there was
a school for the arts right next door
which which did serve a lot of inner
city kids we did we
donated all of our old physics equipment
to them because they didn't have enough
money to buy for even to have a science
lab in that school
and so these that's where you have to
deal with the problems to try and
overcome what may look like a
demographic
inequity or democratic
incompatibility but but but it's so
ridiculous
to say 13 of america's blacks everywhere
we have to have 13
blacks in the physics department um
and and you know that because where
you're going to stop you can say
how many what's the percentage of
redheads what's the percentage of people
who are taller than average
if you really think those things are
significant and and
and i would argue that what martin
luther king said is much more important
to me the quality of intellect
and so i think that this notion that
that their systemic racism first of all
it it flies in the face of everything
i have observed and oh let me and you
know people are going to say well look
my supervisor was black
let me make that clear my graduate
supervisor was black so i've i've
witnessed and i've and
when i was a graduate student in boston
i remember i was going to i was going to
move into an area
uh at boston uh bunker hill i guess and
he said to me you know if you move there
i won't be able to come visit you
and it really you know because boss
boston was incredibly racist and maybe
still is but was incredibly racist at
the time
and so i've seen it's not as if i i i
i'm
ignorant of this i've been involved in
every stage of university levels
and this notion of systemic racism is
just nonsense
well it's also there's a natural time
lag and in that it may not be racist now
and and it may have been racist in the
past or more races let me let me go back
to your favorite subject the nobel prize
yeah okay um when i was at the nobel
prize ceremonies
what the nope and and i and i'm sure
they're not
standing by this now but i wish they
were i was so impressed
because the at the beginning of the
ceremony
there was a woman one woman on the stage
one woman who won the nobel prize
and and and the head of the nobel
committee said you know you'll notice
that there's
one woman uh winning the prize
okay we hope that that will change
but nobel prizes are generally given for
work that's 30 or 40 years old
whether you like it or not and and like
it or not that that's the way
you know there were very few women in
these areas
we hope that 40 years from now there'll
be as many women as men on this stage
but we're not going to
impose that now
because there is a time lag and that's
the point um
um there will be as as in each
it's as as each barrier gets broken as
as
as you overcome social inequities though
those will feed into the system but
again
and yeah here's where i'll get hate
letters while i get them anyway
um maybe you'll get them now too but um
uh you know when when people say look
when i look at
at a gender in in academia and again i i
was chair i would hire the first women
in the physics department
when i was chair at case and um
uh but when people say well look there's
more
women at the assistant professor level
and not as many at the full professor
level and you say to yourself well why
is that
one of the reasons is there weren't many
women
in the faculty and there weren't many
women in that stream
before and and to get to the full
professor level you have to be in this
restaurant so
you would expect in an evolving
situation to have
a better demographic at the assistant
professor level than you have at the
full professor level
because things change and and and that's
but but but somehow to say no no we need
we need
we need to look we need to bean count at
this at the full professor level
because it's not the same as it is at
the junior faculty level it's just to
misunderstand how economy works and i
often feel like there's this total
again or a burros issue you know with
ibrahim
ex candy and and to be anti-racist and
and you know
one of the things you probably don't
miss about academia is that you know how
much of our time is dedicated to
uh the unfalsifiable uh accusation
that we are racist and and i you know
i've had uh eight
black scientists and and and i don't
have them on because they're black
lawrence hemlocks are awesome scientists
and i want to talk to them as i said i
don't have anybody on that i don't
have something that i want to learn from
and and converse about
and then so it's not about and we know
it's academia
i'm so happy to have retired because i
really do think in the united states
academia is largely a lost cause right
now
the quality i want to ask you about that
and it's just going to compared to the
rest of the world is going to continue i
think to be
challenged let me put it that way but
one thing you know i do love about
academia is not only for me but for my
children and my
and my wife we get expo i mean i had
students learns from uganda saudi arabia
every continent including antarctica
which i don't know if you had any
students from antarctica
but uh but the point being that you
didn't have any students that grew up in
antarctica i'll tell you that
i have one that might have been
conceived on anarchy well that's not
going to talk about
yeah that may have happened but
uh but you know certainly in
experimental physics uh you know i would
love nothing better than to discover an
island that harvard hasn't discovered
you know where there are african uh
american citizens yeah that's what
that's
why that's why united states i used to
i've written about this in a different
context when i've written about politics
to the
when people talked about when people
talk about immigrants and
immigration i i i i when i've written to
try and encourage and not discourage
them from allowing
chinese or other graduate students to
come to this country
and i'm not the only one who's done it
but you know we the reason the united
states
continues to for the moment
to be dominant in many areas of science
is because we're able to recruit
the best young people from around the
world some of whom stay in the united
states
and and and and some of them go back to
countries and
do good things and and when that stops
then and when when they go to other
places and i can see it's happening
now already the primary primacy of the
united states will will
will decline because so it's only been
both the gross national product and the
quality of american
educational institutions and research
institutions has only been possible
because
it could if you want to use your term
poach if it could because it could
attract the best young people from
around the world some of whom stay
yeah i saw you know a recent post from
it was from cambridge
you know university and it was uh you
know taking newton
you know not calling them newton's laws
and you know how do you teach them and
then and then they were showing in in
beijing
you know it's like here's your isaac
newton's laws of the universal gravitate
or
my favorite thing nowadays is uh you
know two plus two
equals uh five can be correct because
the notion of right or wrong is somehow
i've written it i've written about that
is yeah you
you know this as well as anybody you're
in california that's what they're
talking about in fact by the way that's
weird
and getting rid of calculus and getting
getting rid of advanced placement
you know ap classes because they're
inequitable it's just ridiculous
no i agree and that's why you know
you're kind of a mystery to me because
but i do want to say you know as well as
i do that some of our best students that
we've encountered come from say
uh from nigeria i've had phenomenal so
not one university i looked at this not
one math department in nigeria teaches
anything other than two plus two equals
four
yeah so in what sense is it and anyway i
love the one question if i could ask
abraham x candy one question it would be
why are you an anti-semite you know why
why are you not doing anti-anti-semitism
actually i'd ask why are you a racist is
what i'd ask
no he said he's not because he's doing
anti-racism
you're absolutely right when it comes to
judaism that's i mean i have to say to
this
i've never i really identified as being
jewish until recently
because i'm because i have a well-known
atheist among other things and judaism
largely as it means very little to me
sorry because i know you're more
more religious but but because of the
the anti-semitism and i've seen it
happening with me now too but
because of the anti-semitism that's
happening i
suddenly want to identify more as being
jewish because of
just my natural contrarian tendency
i want to i want to talk about your
article which was the ideological
corruption of science is the headline in
the wall street journal
and you open up by talking about the
american physical society
who is whose president is now my good
friend uh sylvester james gates
who i've known who not only has been on
my podcast but his daughter's been on my
podcast
she's the second ever african-american
female to graduate from harvard
uh university a place you were a fellow
i mean not not not to graduate from
harvard in physics phd in physics
yeah yeah phd physics african-american
woman i've known i knew
but i knew jim gates by the way when i
was a student and so it was when i he
was at harvard and i was at mit and then
we were harvard
uh in the society of fellows so i think
you wrote this in 2020
and in the summer you know following the
george floyd killing
et cetera and the title of a video kind
of above it is
opinion the left consumes the left so
everything you're talking about you know
if i just you know covered up your name
and your twitter profile and
and some of your past interviews um you
know people think you're like a rabid
you know right winger or you know
conservative now like
everything you're uh aligned with and
people like peter berghausian who's been
a guest on the podcast
and as a friend and noam chomsky you had
a conversation with gnome uh three weeks
ago on origins podcast that was just you
know really shocking
terrifying but it's like no i didn't you
call the republican party the greatest
terrorist organization on earth you know
it's like
and i'll talk to anyone called a
right-wing pundit now which breaks me up
as
someone who's always thought of himself
as incredibly left-wing yeah i've had on
my show i've had ben shapiro and michael
knowles probably people you don't care
so much for it
no no no well i mean no i i become much
older and more tolerant as time goes on
i want to ask you about judaism because
you brought it up and i'm going to ask
about it
um i often use you and i with with the
utmost respect lawrence i always say you
know lawrence
uh is so bright uh but you know when it
comes to judaism and and i haven't
pointed out you know
i don't i don't send you typos and
things like that but but
you know if lawrence if my ten-year-old
comes up to you and says lawrence you
know i
i found that a professor crouch he'd be
very respectful unlike his father but
anyway
you say dr krause you know you are
amazing um but you know there's logical
flaws
throughout a universe from nothing and
or you know philosophical or
even mathematically you say get out of
here you you know 10 12 year old kid you
don't know anything
you don't have enough experience
generating wisdom you might have
wikipedia
why i don't think you'd say that
especially a 10 year old i'd want to
hear what they have to say it's the
adults i'm not so interested my 10 year
old will
blow your mind okay fine and i love when
kids come up with things to see as i say
it's the adults that bother me yeah
the the thing i'm getting at lawrence is
that um i i want to know if you're
anti-religion
if you're anti-christian i don't really
care so much about that but the point
i'm trying to make is not ending any of
that i'm just
i'm an apathyist yeah so i mean god
means nothing to me right so and you
talked about this with woody allen on
your show
and and he's famous for saying you know
i'll settle for a divine sneeze my point
that i'm trying to make
is that um your education in judaism to
the extent you had it now i was born
i didn't have yeah you were bar mitzvah
i was just going to say that okay
and that was probably the culmination of
your g i wasn't bar mitzvahed that's
what i mean
oh you weren't okay see for me i wasn't
i was an altar boy
i want you to know that that turned me
into an anti-semite for a while
yeah exactly yeah the whole experience
was so disgusting that i
i i i wanted nothing to do with it for
the longest time
as it did for my father who was a
militant atheist himself a toyota
a term i think you coined um and are
proud of but but the punishment
i know i've argued that militant atheism
is a is a is a um
oxymoron what does it mean you throw
papers at buildings i don't know what it
means to
anyway but okay militant passage yeah
anyway
uh but but the point is um you know your
formal
education you know might have culminated
with your bar mitzvah probably certainly
did i didn't know that you were turned
off from your
uh from judaism at that point but in
other words there what about you and one
of my
audience is asking this question what
about jesus the most famous jew who ever
lived
are there things about judaic faith
um that are emulatable are there
principles are there
are is there redeemable aspects of it or
is
is the entirety of it if it's shaped by
this experience that you had as a young
as a 12 year old 13 year old no look
first of all i was growing up to revere
this
my mother convinced me that being jewish
involved questioning and wanting to
learn and all these things which i
you know i buy into that somewhat i mean
i i don't think it's
certainly unique but there is a but i
think the notion of questioning the
talmudic notion
of questioning is wonderful because for
me questioning is everything so i'd say
if you you've had to pick one sort of
thing that i really do
think is culturally jewish
that is enviable or that that
that derives from the religiosity which
isn't enviable
it's the talmetic basis of questioning
of trying to work through through
questioning
because that's the basis of
understanding so i would say that that's
a very
noble thing but but the rest of the
the the whole religious basis of judaism
i find completely ridiculous
and and the notion um so and but you
know but having said that
i will point out that i'm no expert um
yeah
and in fact i may know as much about
islam as i do about judaism in some ways
i was just going to say
you know my um do you know i call you
when you're not around
uh behind your back i call you a devout
israelite
because uh not a jew but you know what
the word israel means in hebrew
what does it mean it means fights
against god
okay yeah because jacob uh whose name
was later changed
anyway it's the notion and it's the
opposite is islam what does islam mean
in
uh in arabic it means submission so
they're
completely diametrically opposed one is
submit to god and completely
and the other one is to fight and
wrestle with as the talmud does
yeah and you know well in principle yeah
but let's not pretend that the old
testament isn't as violent and horrific
as
as as as the koran i mean stone your
children if they disobey you
i mean it sounds nice but the difference
is and i would say that
and i've again it's not a very profound
or
deep intellectual study that i've done
in this regard
but the difference is that islam is 600
years younger
so 600 years ago they might take that
nonsense literally
and and do the worst possible things and
now we say yeah but okay we don't you
know that's okay but we don't buy that
stuff
we have a kind of gentler religion now
and so i just think part of the problem
of islam is that they're in the phase of
taking all the nonsense literally
including them in fact let me just say a
hatred and a vective that's
that's let me just say about the endemic
to all sacred texts including the new
testament i would argue
let me let me just say about the stoning
um so that's very interesting and i
wasn't planning to go on this way but i
do want to point out that no
so what the stoning says is that the
parents may not stone their kids
and there's oh big deal but back in the
ancient world
as is in the current modern world the
notion of honor killings was
predominantly for the first time in
human history judaism took the power to
kill your child out of the parent's hand
now
the parent has to take the child to the
sanhedrin then the sanhedrin
there's no record and you know the
talmud the germans and the assyrians
everybody
has used the talmud to skewer the jews
because there's no book that's more
anti-semitic than
than the talmud you know it's saying how
awful we are and how bad but anyway
lawrence the point is and and same with
like divorce like people think of
the treatment of women and it's true
they had but there was a first time in
human history
when a woman could be an agent and be
self-deterministic and could get a
divorce
and if the man did not give her a
divorce he would get stoned well it's
major article well they were smart i
mean it was very important
well there's a good reason to be major
article i mean the one thing about
the jewish religion is it that i've
always
enjoyed is that or at least appreciated
it seemed to me not or at least the
culture
is that it's based on thinking
intelligently about
how to get around things and and and um
and it's smart to be matriarchal because
you know ten percent of fathers aren't
the fathers
and you know who the mother is and yeah
yeah um
but but look i'm not saying that look
these were ignorant pet these were the
the by
to the extent that the bible was written
in any time it was a time
of a ignorance and b
violence and hatred and and it's
characteristic of that
so having understanding that is not to
demean
the jewish religion which arose out of
it it's just to say
it came i mean that we shouldn't
we shouldn't revere these ancient books
that are
that are um really written at times that
happily
science and other things have allowed us
to overcome although i think shakespeare
is quite excellent and those times were
times of endemic poverty and
ignorance and illiteracy and we we we
look for that what we do and i've always
been a student of history
and and and actually anyway
first book i was working on was a
history book but the the
um we should appreciate and understand
the history and and and and the wisdom
of the fact because because basically
things don't change the more things
change the more they stay the same
so it's worth looking for the gems of
wisdom
in in shakespeare and it's worth looking
in the bible for
for for things that are that are are
gems of wisdom about the human condition
perhaps
yeah but it's not worth claiming it's a
it's
it's a it's a sacred text any more than
it is to say
shakespeare's because some of his plays
stink okay
no that and and um and so it's not it's
not
and that's that's the problem and and
and and
so i guess i grew up in an area you see
i was grew up in an area that was
completely jewish i didn't know there
were i thought jews were the majority
until i was 12 and then i moved to an
area where there were no jews
and and but i was always brought up with
this kind of a feat
view that somehow it's something special
and wonderful about
judaism and i guess i try to rebel about
that of course i appreciate the
the the
many of the cultural aspects but but i
also understand that there are other
equally
uh uh um laudable cultural aspects that
have nothing to do with judaism
no i just i just always do rail again i
mean there there is
my dream is to adopt a havrusa
mechanism with you uh where the two
partners sit down and they take one
sugiya one passage one equation
basically
and they just beat each other up about
it and the goal is not to look
during the holocaust there's famous
stories about rappers
by the way that's the way i have always
preceded my research with my students
that's exactly and the way it was when i
was with shelley glacier when i was at
harvard yeah
you sit in a room and you argue and you
complain and you and and and
and that's fun yeah yeah and and there
is wisdom i asked andrewian
as i'm going to ask you in about 10
minutes you know kind of the
immortal words of wisdom that she wishes
humanity would adopt and she quoted from
the book of mika
and she's a devout atheist as you know
and carl sagan as a humanist rather i
know her and she quoted and
except for you know act justly love
mercy and uh
and that's it the last word for those of
you who don't know in mika is walk
humbly with your god but anyway
i do want to ask some questions from my
audience but before i do that so anyway
my dream if we are together is to take
you to a shabbat
dinner because it's almost impossible
not to enjoy that and the second i've
been
studying together yeah yeah my favorite
tom when i
when i was at at mit as a grad student i
guess when i was alone and i thought
well okay i may as well explore my roots
i went to
i went to uh passover seder at put on by
the rabbi
one of whatever the official people are
in in
i forget what that group is called but
anyway um hello that's right
um and um and it was it was a really
enjoyable experience one of the
one of the one of my favorite things was
the the detailed question of
uh you know he held a wine glass this
isn't a wine glass if i i would if this
were empty well maybe no
yeah well maybe hold on again sorry
you know this one from the so he said
the rabbi said why
why do we hold the wine glass like this
and everyone was discussing in these
guys he said because if you hold like
this all the wine goes out
and i thought that that was that was
anyway
yeah that's right that's right yeah i
mean for me it's much more practical
there's there's it's very hard to
imagine that you know secular and i've
spoken at the ethical humanist society
of chicago which is one of the foremost
and oldest and i've spoken at churches
and
and synagogues the one skinny guy i was
wouldn't be wasn't allowed to speak that
was
orthodox synagogue in cleveland because
i indicated them that i was going to say
the world was more than six thousand
years old and they wouldn't let me speak
anyway yeah so i yeah i personally don't
know
and i believe that but but they but the
rabbis that i traffic in and
of course yeah this is not something you
know that you know because
we can get into that in our next
conversation okay now i'm distracted i
want to first
ask you about hype so we talk about hype
and i want to ask you about um
artificial intelligence
the claim is that artificial
intelligence is going to eventually
produce
you know artificial galileo and i've
actually worked with since i now have
the text
one million words of his dialogue in
printed form
for the first time to make the audio
book i am going to uh put it into gpt3
and see if i can teach him qed or you
know
whatever but but to just see what what
will come out of it because i think
it'll be interesting
but my my assumption is that
just because uh computers can beat any
human at chess
it doesn't mean they can create the game
of chess in other words uh
they can't they can solve a rubik's cube
can they invent a rubik's cube
but in the essence of physics the note
the claim is that it's just a you know
max tag mark has written about this
you know it's just a matter of time
before we have artificial finemen
and i claim that will never happen
because you know first of all
yeah okay go on let me yeah i was just
gonna say the
the uh when einstein do you know what
einstein called the happiest thought of
his life not fantasy but the happiest
thought of his life
lawrence i i seem to remember it but
remind me as a no sense
is that if you were in free fall you'd
experience zero exactly yeah
yeah yeah gravity would be uh
acceleration
he called that the hat now how can a
computer and that's what led to gr you
know in some sense
um how can a computer a know what it
feels to free fall
b know what uh know what happiness is
in this context and see how can they
take that intellectual leap
if you're just taking data from newton
and showed the perihelion and mercury
anomalously advances
how would you possibly get from that you
know lacunae
in the data to a new way of thinking
about a fundamental force so
those are my opinions what do you think
about i think i think you're being
short-sighted but i also think these
other people are being ridiculous i mean
first of all anytime you hear people
predict things about things we don't
know anything about
they call themselves futurists often
that's when those are people you
shouldn't listen to
um and almost invariably they miss the
important stuff
i mean we were supposed to be in flying
cars and you know when in the 1950s but
when they talked about 2000 but they
didn't talk about the internet
but um but uh uh
i think the what's clear is that
um you're you're
you're making presumptions based on the
present of what
um of what uh well first of all we don't
even know what intelligence is in some
deep sense but but
you're making the assumptions that you
know i can't input all of the
um the sensory uh uh
data input that you would feel in free
fall and and and
and and you're so for me
i see no barriers ultimately
to what you would call a an artificial
consciousness but it's not the problem
with artificial intelligence is not
artificial in any sense
yeah it's it's it's really mimicking in
some way
the intelligence that it's it's it's
creating a
a an electronic version of a system that
arrives haphazardly by biology
and and and biology did it very
effectively because it had a long time
to do it um
so i don't see any barriers to
ultimately what you would call computers
being conscious
i i ultimately don't see
computer fineman is not the way of
putting it but what i i
am interested in in um
uh a general artificial intelligence in
in in those using those language which i
don't like
um precisely for the same reason i think
that feynman was
which is i would like to know
what an intelligent computer what
physics questions an intelligent
computer would find interesting
and there's not it's not at all clear to
me that they'd be the same questions
it's to me it's just like wanting to
know about an alien intelligence
i would love to have an alien
intelligence because i'd like to learn a
lot about what they've learned about the
world and how they think about it
because it would illuminate
presumably potentially a completely
different way of thinking about the
world than i'm used to
so i don't see it as a say a threat in
that sense nor do i see it as a panacea
i see it i think in the long run is kind
of inevitable but not in any but i mean
long run i don't think
all ai is an area that's incredibly
hyped
you're absolutely right computers can
beat people at chess but they can't
but robots can't yet really effectively
fold laundry
um and so um you know this notion of
you know around the corner
that's going to happen i think it's
ridiculous but i i personally don't see
it as a
as a problem and and the example
i wrote about this once in an article
that that um
was going to be in a book but they
removed it uh on ai
um a few years ago um
that anyway it doesn't matter where it
was um
i'm interested i find it fascinating
that plato and others
going back to plato and in full circle
around the time that writing was first
invented
totally decried writing because they
said it would ruin storytelling
storytelling be over because people
wouldn't have memories they wouldn't be
able to do this stuff and of course it
didn't happen
so what it did is it changed things and
i think that as
as in as computational systems become
more capable in different areas
um it will change things but i don't see
um i i guess i don't see the same beer i
think you're just
imposing the present on the future
who knows what the origins of creativity
is except it's making connections
at some level between disparate things
in some way i don't see any barrier
ultimately to a
a computer with sufficient sent input
from a variety of things to be able to
not understand
what what if how happy it is to fall
in the absence of gravity uh uh uh or
or even sense it in any sense that we
sense it
because i was just listening to a
actually a wonderful
i like bill bryson a lot and and i was
listening to his book on the body and he
points out
a very important fact that that we feel
pain
in the everywhere we feel pain in the
brain
okay not in the fingers not when not the
ones that are being burned it's in the
brain that it's created
and and it's and it's created because of
a whole bunch of biochemical reactions
that relate to sensory input
and i don't see that electrochemical
reactions or electrical reactions
related to similar sensory input can't
create the same
feelings in that artificial brain but
that's right yeah
okay yeah i've thought about that you
know if you want to teach some pain you
know blow a capacitor here
and a resistor there you know yeah maybe
it's a mechanism that was developed
and so why wouldn't they i mean they may
not who knows i mean it's
it's this whole it's this fundamental
physical philosophical question
which none of us can ever really answer
which is how do i know that your pain is
the same as my pain
how do i know that you're green even
though i'm colorblind that your green is
the same as my green
i'm writing a new uh a new book what is
it like to be thomas nagel
under the pseudonym a bat my nickname
and i think my name is going to be
okay lawrence we've reached the
lightning round okay uh first i'm going
to ask you
um uh some questions for my audience
then the lightning round then we're
going to close up
with because my wife is going to be very
angry because we were going to go all
right yeah
i'm sorry the river behind our house in
a moment all right
so um so this could be a lightning one
word answer
uh is jesus christ a good role model
from
my my viewer emmanuel kant emmanuel kant
is my
wow it's very very i wow he's a very
dead guy he's very
very uh prolific but um um is jesus a
good role model worth emulating he has
um
not particularly no i mean i mean some
of the things look what i don't know
what you're a role model i think that
that um whatever that means no i mean he
said certain things well he's purported
to have said certain things that are
that are certainly worth worth uh
appreciating and respecting
um
and but no i'm not
no not particularly okay um
would you like to sit down and have a
conversation with your fellow countryman
jordan peterson
oh yes and i have and i will okay yeah
in fact i have in fact
for for for for this i i just had a long
conversation with jordan peterson that's
going to appear on his podcast uh
on monday i think and okay and he's
going to be on mine yeah
even though yeah because i'm very become
very magnanimous as i've gotten older
yes that's right you've uh you've
mellowed man you've changed man
since you moved to canada yeah the great
mellow north well uh next question
will do it anyway do you feel like it
was fair fair of your assessors to fail
you
in your first phd viva on the basis that
he knew maths
but not physics this comes from rajeev
gungel um he
recently said although it was traumatic
he learned a lesson oh absolutely
yeah absolutely and and and the it was
incredibly important because i was
uh because physics is phenomenal and if
you're not in touch with phenomena
you're not doing physics
great uh easy question from uh listener
aj
uh what happened before the big bang
my answer is uh potentially it's a bad
question
okay um how can an
average and for the reasons i said
earlier time may not have existed so
that's not a good question
yeah and yeah and the other answer is i
don't know
which is a answer that we should all use
more often to almost all questions
sorry go on um should we trust the same
government that makes us
uh you know as miss covid at first
denied it then has gone into complete
you know opposite direction
should we trust the same government that
enacted various
um suppressive and also amplification
of information should we trust them to
tell us what to do when it comes to
climate change
which we didn't get to talk to but we
yeah you didn't in my my new book you
didn't even pop
you didn't even plug it but give away a
copy how about that no but we didn't
never trust anyone no look that's the
reason i wrote the book
the point is educate yourselves
at some level and as a point of the book
almost anyone can understand
the fundamental science behind climate
change and the really basic predictions
it doesn't require
supercomputers to understand the basic
science behind climate change and it's
fascinating science
and my point there's no policies
recommendations in my book
the point is to say that that
one that that policy first you have to
understand
reality and then you can decide a policy
and so the point is that never
obviously don't trust anyone try and um
understand it and then impact on
government because what governments
never do is lead what they always do is
follow
and i learned that from noam chomsky
when i was a graduate student
about vietnam ultimately
what governments will do how the
government way governments respond to
climate change will depend upon
the public and it will only be rational
if the public has a rational
ultimately rationally demands policies
okay anyway uh next question
uh comes from lucas pattison
who asks can we sacrifice our
politicians
to an active volcano to save ourselves
from climate change and if so
who would you choose active politician
that has to be an active politician
active okay let me let me just say this
um politicians
are politicians and that's and and and
that that that
means they have very specific jobs
and and and uh and of course
part of being a politician involves
doing things that a lot of people would
not want to do
in order to get elected but i will say
this and maybe because i'm influenced
because i was just speaking to a
congressional aide the other day who
one of the things i'm very proud of is
my foundation
and i'm not profiting from this in case
anyone figures it but we just we sent
copies of the
physics of climate change to every
member of congress um
raised money to do it um and because why
because we want them to just
again it's not it's not a democratic
issue it's not a republican issue it's
not a left or right issue
it's just a science and then they can
decide on policy
but but i've testified before congress
uh officially on one occasion me and
buzz aldrin many years ago on the future
of space exploration
i've lectured to i've i've i've given
what what for what they're called briefs
before congress and and
congratulations and every time i do it i
come away
more impressed with the people working
hard on behalf
of people than i am when i listen to the
news or watch the news
so i will say that on the whole in
washington there are many people and in
canada
in ottawa and other places there are
many people working very hard
uh on behalf of of of what they think
is right and um and so let's just say
that
that's helpful and that reminds me of a
joke uh what's the opposite of
the pros of something the the the poetry
of something
no the the pro i know when you said
you didn't get my joke okay i got them
okay anyway what's the opposite of the
pros
what's the opposite of pro where
finished it's almost finished
yeah what's the opposite of pro when
someone says you want the pros and the
the cons obviously right so what's the
opposite of progress
congress okay yeah yeah yeah all right
good all right last couple of questions
i know you're busy um
apologize blame it on me some some can i
talk now i was gonna tell you what i was
gonna
now i have to tell you my one joke too
okay go for it because it's
it's related to your questions about
judaism and the questioning thing
you probably know this joke about this
uh grandmother takes her grandson to the
beach
and um he's sitting there and and he's
playing at the beach with his ball and a
big wave comes up and
and swallows him and takes him out to
the and disappears and she looks up she
goes god god
please he's a wonderful young boy he
shouldn't end his life this way please
please don't don't don't kill him
the big wave comes back and lands him
back on the beach
and she looks up and says he had a hat
anyway all right we have reached the end
now i have the final three questions if
you'll
indulge and give me some of that good
christian forbearance that you're known
for
uh and these involve uh things related
to arthur c
clarke who is the namesake of the center
which i co-direct that hosted you many
years ago
and uh the first one is going to take us
to the biblical age of 120
and it involves a so-called ethical not
material will
but your ethical will so alfred nobel
had partially
established an ethical will by ensuring
or hoping to enshrine that the benefit
to mankind would be the greatest uh you
know accomplishment
of the laureates so anyway so he had won
the famous ones go back jesus and and
barack obama wrote an ethical will it's
called the zava
in hebrew anyway what would you like to
convey in wisdom
or knowledge and ethical uh imperatives
when you spring forth this mortal coil
at the biblical age that moses achieved
of 120 years that's a question i can't
answer i don't really think in those
terms
i am i am
um i have no
um i have no uh that i have no
legacy or if you want to cut
that i would want to leave other than
the work that i've done during my life
that's all
okay nothing all right next question
involves a monolith
spotted in 2001 a space odyssey which is
some kind of a time capsule
and it's this question relates to
feynman's question of if
in some cataclysm all scientific
knowledge would be destroyed
and only one sentence passed on to the
next generation of creatures
what statement would contain the most
information in the fewest words you
wrote a book about it called adam that
was his answer
what about humanity discoveries
in physics is most impressive that you
would use as sort of a talisman to put
on a billion-year-long
arthur t clark like time capsule okay
let me this is going to be a problem
with all your questions
it's it's a fundamental it's a
personality problem of mine maybe you
can call it character trait
i don't think hierarchically i never
have so i don't think of most this or
most that i like a lot of different
things so i
i rarely list my favorite book my
favorite one but
but you know so so so to to pick one
thing
um but you say what what thing would i
put on a time capsule
what what piece of information about the
physical universe do you feel
encapsulates the most amount of
information in sort of the most compact
form as
feynman said yeah feynman yeah wrote
about that at one point what he put in
um yeah yeah actually i think i think
let me there's i i could have argued
something else
um you know i might have said the
statement from galileo where he says but
yet it moves
um would maybe be because
from there you can build all of physics
so it's the it's the seed from which all
of physics builds
so that's one thing i might say but i
think the other thing i would say
and i've written about this and for
undergraduates actually um
is the hubble constantly rate because
basically
every major feature of our universe
comes from that one quantity
you can understand the age of the
universe almost everything from that to
one dimensional quantity
so the expansion rate of the universe is
in my mind the most important global
quantity describing the universe
okay excellent all right the last
question lawrence relates to the title
of my podcast
and that is a saying of arthur c
clarke which takes us backwards in time
he said the only way
of discovering the limits of the
possible is to venture a little way past
them
into the impossible that's the origin of
the name of this podcast
but i want to ask you going back in time
to a 20 year old 30 year old lawrence
krauss
is there any advice that you would give
yourself to help you
have courage and so forth to go into the
impossible
well as i say i mean my job has been to
think about the possibilities which
means to find out
what you know how to turn the possible
into the possible so that's what i
my job has been that way but the advice
i'd give
myself and i i tend to try not to give
too much advice
um would be the same advice i always
give young people which is don't let the
bastards get you down
i think i had a t-shirt like that when i
was a kid except it was turkeys and i
was an elephant but i didn't wear it
because i got teased for being fat
lawrence krauss director of the origins
project foundation
a non-profit which can be accessed at
the websites in the
video description below or on the uh
text audio description
also the proprietor of the origins
podcast uh lawrence has been fun we
should
catch up more often than every nine
years yeah wow it's been no it's truly a
lifeline i wouldn't have spent
two and a half hours with you if it
hadn't been and and i'm
pleased that you did your homework which
is always uh to me the first step of uh
of quality and so but it was great yeah
i kind of miss you i'd like to yeah
so yeah i should come to be fun i i
should come up there
you're not allowed here right now
because i know you have to be
quarantined
like i am anyway they're spiding us all
right lauren have a great day sorry i
kept you so long we'll probably break it
into two episodes okay i have a
wonderful question i have to apologize
to my wife more than me
i will just send her my way i haven't
come off
yeah okay tell you what lawrence when
she when you guys come and visit in
january i'll probably be able to make it
up for
for that okay okay yeah okay take care
bye-bye be well
thank you any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
if you enjoyed this video i know you'll
want to check out my interview with
frank wilcheck winner of the 2004 nobel
prize
in this conversation frank and i discuss
this fascinating new book
called fundamentals which outlines 10
key principles to understand our
universe
and don't forget to subscribe